Das war's für heute.
Die Zutaten sind in der Infobox aufgelistet.
So, moin Leute, jetzt haben wir erstmal unsere Morgengymnastik durchgeführt.
Jetzt können wir Stream so an anfangen, mal kurz was gucken nebenbei, wartet mal kurz,
ganz schnell was schauen, ja ok alles klar, passt.
Ja, ich weiß nicht wie lange heute Vormittag gestreamt wird, bis wir alle wach sind,
ja, aber vielleicht nicht ganz so lange wie sonst.
Mal gucken, dass wir nachher noch eine Runde weiter programmieren können,
aber heute Nachmittag erst dann am Labelchamp.
Da haben wir ja gestern tatsächlich wieder erwartet, obwohl ich eine Stunde am Anfang
geschwätzt habe, relativ viel Progress gemacht.
So, ja Chat, was hab ich verpasst, irgendwas spannendes passiert heute Nacht?
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Haben sich wieder irgendwelche YouTuber gebieft oder sind irgendwelche Minister zurückgedreht
oder irgendwas?
Hab ich heute Nacht irgendwas verpasst?
Nö, nicht wirklich, ich guck grad mal irgendwelche üblichen News Seiten, aber da gibt's nichts.
Nix passiert, ja was soll auch zwischen heute und gestern irgendwie heute Nacht großartig
passiert sein.
So, exzellent.
Rittititeditidin, Rittititeditidin.
Okay ich bin ready, auf gehts!
Du musst vor 13 Uhr weg, tja, heute, sonntags, Eier suchen, oder?
Hättest du der Backup kaputt gegangen, ja aber das ist ja nichts neues, das ist ja
schon kaputt gegangen vor drei Tagen oder so, ist ja schon ein bisschen her.
Letztendlich ist der Raid 6 kaputt gegangen, soweit ich das richtig gelesen habe.
Pe-Po-Fat, Pe-Po-Fat werden, ja das ist auch eine gute Idee.
Leute, ich, ich hab abgenommen, die letzten, die letzten Monate über, die letzten zwei
Monate hab ich jetzt insgesamt sogar schon 6 Kilo abgenommen.
Und wenn das so weiter geht, soll ich euch mal, soll ich euch mal den Pe-Po-Fat Graf
zeigen von meiner Waage, den muss ich euch screenshotten.
Ich, ich hab ja, ich hab ja Auswertung meiner, meiner Waage, ja.
Leute, ich muss doch mal kurz Mails, Mails checken.
Oh nee, da will ich nicht hin.
Einladung zum deutschen Streamer, zur deutschen Streamer-Party, oh Gott, nein, nein, nein,
nein.
Party, let's wait, Keg-Wait, Alter, Real-Life-Stell, es geht mir fort.
Ich muss grad mal schnell in meine Mails gucken, ich hab da seit zwei Wochen oder so nicht mehr
reingeschaut.
Deutsche Streamer-Party, also das sind zwei Kombinationen, die ich nicht mag, Offline-Events
mit vielen Leuten auf engem Raum und, und, deutsche YouTube slash Streamer-Szene, das
sind ja zwei Dinge, damit kann ich überhaupt nichts anfangen, das ist doppelt, doppelt
no, ja.
Und nicht so, dass zweimal Minus irgendwie plus wird.
Na ja, ich wollt euch meine, den Waagen-Screenshot zeigen, Sekunde, Bart, man, man erkennt,
das ist ja doof, irgendwie hab ich den, den Zeitraum umgestellt, guckt mal, Zack, Paint,
ich hab den Zeitraum umgestellt, das, das zeigt jetzt bloß noch irgendwie zwei Wochen,
das müsste eigentlich länger zeigen, bald wieder, bald wieder unter 100 Club, Alter,
noch zwei, drei Wochen oder so, wie kann ich denn, ich muss mal kurz gucken, wie kann
ich jetzt einstellen, dass der die, die Waage länger, länger einstellt, Scale, Minicraft,
hours to show, aha, kann er noch mehr, Moment, ich, der soll einfach noch mehr schauen, jetzt,
jetzt hängt die Seite, das ist natürlich auch Müll, warte mal, ich muss mal kurz
mal den Graph anpassen, ja, wirklich gut funktioniert das net, na, also ich, ich krieg den Graph
nicht angepasst, was auch immer, ich kann euch den Pepofet-Progress nicht zeigen, aber
ich hab ja die History, wartet mal, Logbuch, Moment, Moment, ich such, ich such jetzt mal,
ich muss das jetzt mal ausprobieren, Verlauf, aber Waage, Waage, selbst mal gucken, wie das
funktioniert, so, Waage, mehr Anzeigen, Verlauf, so, und zwar von, keine Ahnung, nehmen wir
mal, letztes Jahr bis heute, na, meine History reicht nicht aus, ich hab bloß 14 Tage History,
was ist denn das, warum hab ich nur 14 Tage History gespeichert, das ist ja richtig Weirdchamp,
ja, dann erkennt man das ja gar nicht richtig, also vor 14 Tagen, guckt mal Leute, ich kann
euch zeigen, dass es runtergeht, guckt mal, Huge Wagencraft, guckt mal, mehr sieht man
leider nicht, mehr sieht man leider nicht, da war es noch 103,5 und dann ging das permanent
runter, die Zeit hier unten ist, glaube ich, etwas komisch, weil es nicht gerade, weil
es nicht langsam geht, sondern quasi so abgehackt, aber so im Prinzip, im Prinzip sieht man
es ja, leider, leider fehlen, das fehlt das davor, das war mal 107, Alter, ich war mal
richtig pepo fett, ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich weniger fett wäre mit 101, aber, also
ich hoffe ja, dass ich es irgendwann schaffe, wenn ich so weitermache, also das einzige,
was ich mache, ganz ehrlich, ich futtere, also ich ess nix süßes mehr, ich bin 174,
also ich bin richtig pepo fett, zum Glück, zum Glück habe ich den Vorteil, oder weiß
ich auch nicht, ob man das als Vorteil nehmen kann, dass ich an sich nicht nur rund bin,
sondern auch halbwegs breit, das heißt, das sieht nicht ganz so ultra pepo fett bauchmäßig
aus, aber es ist trotzdem ziemlich dick, so und das einzige, was ich jetzt mache, ist
seit zwei Monaten, ich habe, aber von einem Tag auf den anderen, ich habe mich auf die
Waage gestellt und habe irgendwie Andy 108 gehabt, da habe ich mir gedacht, nee, das
geht so nicht weiter, gerade jetzt die ganze Zeit mit Corona daheim und richtig viel fressen
und alles, das geht so nicht weiter, ich habe von einem Tag auf den anderen, ich habe aufgehört
jeglichen Süßkram zu futtern, also das höchste der Gefühle, was ich esse, ist vielleicht
mal irgendwie, weiß ich gar nichts mehr, vielleicht noch ein Plätzchen oder so, eins, so, ich
esse keinerlei Süßkram mehr und ich esse viel, viel weniger Fett, ich habe ja früher,
wenn ich Pommes frites gefuttert habe, habe ich da gefühlt irgendwie eine Viertelflasche
Mayonnaise noch zum Tunken und so gemacht, mache ich jetzt gar nicht mehr und allgemein,
ein wenig gesünder, aber was ich halt gar nicht auf die Reihe bekomme, das habe ich
im Frühjahr schon mal probiert, was ich gar nicht auf die Reihe bekomme, ist die Menge
krass zu reduzieren, weil dann habe ich Hunger und fange irgendwann an wieder ekliches und
ungesundes Zeug zu futtern, also ich futter immer noch fast normale Menge, aber halt viel
weniger Süßkram und viel weniger Fett und ich bewege mich ein bisschen mehr und das hat
bis jetzt gereicht, ja, natürlich ist das jetzt nicht so die mega, mega huge krass Diät,
aber die halte ich eh nicht durch, also ich mache nicht demnächst Gatchirol oder so, aber
es funktioniert, mal gucken, mal gucken, also mein Ziel ist es ja erst einmal jetzt unter
100 zu kommen und vielleicht so im Laufe des nächsten Jahres vielleicht mal an die 90,
das reicht mir ja schon, mal gucken, mal gucken, Leute, ich kann euch ja ab und zu mal einen
updated Wagencraft im Stream zeigen, ihr könnt mich auch danach fragen, da kann ich mich
nicht rausreden mit, ich trage das ja per Bluetooth Low Energy, zeige euch den Graph,
bei 90 Kilo Face Reveal, Face Reveal hat nichts mit meinem Gewicht zu tun, Face Reveal hat
was mit meinen YouTube Abos zu tun, sollte ich irgendwann mal 100, irgendwann mal eine
Million Abos erreichen, mache ich Face Reveal, mit dem Unterschied, dass ich wahrscheinlich
nie eine Million Abos erreichen werde, weil ich jetzt erst einmal 300k Abos erreichen
werde irgendwann dieses Jahr, hoffe ich mal, ja, einfach, einfach bewegen, tatsächlich,
das ist unglaublich was das alles bringt, das ist auch kreislauftechnisch viel besser,
tja, das gibt es auch umgedreht, naja, so, interessiert wird keinem wirklich, gucken
wir mal, was schauen wir uns denn, mit der Katz spazieren gehen, mit der Katz spazieren
gehen funktioniert nicht, aber die Katz, die darf mittlerweile auf den Balkon, guckt mal,
schicko finde das wahnsinnig toll, schau, oh Gott, Twitter, warum ist Twitter eigentlich
so, es gibt doch, jetzt mal ernsthaft, es gibt keinen Grund, dass mich Twitter, wenn
ich hier auf Media klicke, zum Einloggen zwingt, keinen, gar keinen, also rein benutzungstechnisch,
dass die Accounts abgreifen wollen, ist klar, der Frazier wird geteilt, hat der mal was
gepostet in letzter Zeit, ne, ach so, ja sein Stream von seinen neuen Arbeitsplatz, naja,
ähm, guckt mal, die Katz, die darf jetzt auf die Terrasse, nein, das legt die krass,
was meint ihr, chat, ist die Katze zu dick oder ist die Fensterbank zu klein, ja, also
die Katze findet das super, die darf jetzt auf die Terrasse raus mit mir und das findet
die ganz ganz toll, spazieren gehen mit der Katze ist nicht, aber draus in der Sonne rumliegen,
das findet die ganz ganz ganz toll, das findet die sozusagen Pogge, Pogge, Poggie, Poggie,
man muss sich das mal vorstellen, es hat vor 14 Tagen geschneit, gut, nein, das wollen
wir jetzt nicht gucken, das wollen wir jetzt auch nicht gucken, Fensterbank zu klein, ja,
denke ich auch, so, was empfiehlt uns YouTube denn für schöne Sachen heute, zeigt mal her,
was verdient ein Rohrleitungsbauer, das interessiert mich ehrlich gesagt nicht so, mich interessiert
was der kostet vielleicht, wenn er mir Rohre baut und ich hätte mal mehr Leerrohre bauen
lassen sollen zum Kabel verlegen im Haus, jetzt ist aber zu spät, weil jetzt sind die
Wände zu und jetzt kann man auch nichts mehr reinlegen, wie Simplicissimus angegriffen
wird, aha, mit dem Internet nicht jeder irgendwie geflamed von allen Seiten, so kannst du eigentlich
machen was du willst, das ist doch komplett normal, was, Russenbots, gibt es die wirklich
in der Masse, es wird ja an jeder Stelle gesagt so nach dem Motto, ah hier, russische Bots,
sind das denn alles wo man immer denkt, das sind russische Bots, sind das dann alles wirklich
immer russische Bots oder sind das vielleicht nicht unbedingt Bots, sondern Leute, die ein
bisschen verwirrt im Kopf sind, klick drauf, nee ich will das jetzt nicht gucken, oder
mal gucken, komm wir machen das auf vielleicht, fährt er wieder in GTA im Kreis, nee, normalerweise
fährt er doch immer GTA im Kreis, also was empfiehlt uns, can lego move a full glass
of water, water, ja das können wir uns nachher anschauen, wir lassen uns erstmal gibaten
von levelcap, almost everyone still, ich weiß gar nicht ob ich lachen oder weinen soll,
wahrscheinlich sind das wirklich so aussagen die von dice kommen oder so, muss ich mal
kurz gucken wo das herkommt, glaub den Scheiß irgendjemand, ok ich mein daran arbeiten heißt
nicht Vollzeit daran arbeiten, am tags sich einmal die neuesten, einmal git pull zu machen
im battlefield 2042 repo gilt auch als arbeiten und es ist auch die frage wer almost everyone
ist, wenn von ursprünglich 100 nur noch 10 leute im team sind dann arbeitet auch almost
everyone dran, also das ist ja totaler bullshit wieder, die erzählen ein dünn schiss das
ist nicht zu fassen und wisst ihr was noch fast tragischer ist, wisst ihr was noch fast
tragischer ist, wenn das stimmen sollte das wirklich noch fast jeder dran arbeitet vom
original team, das ist absolut beschämend, stellt euch mal vor du hast keine ahnung
ich sag jetzt einfach mal 400 leute an einem game arbeiten seit 6 monaten und das einzige
was du geschafft hast ist 3 blog posts wo du neue kisten platzieren willst auf ner map
und ein scoreboard was auch nicht frostbite kenner wahrscheinlich in 3-4 tagen gemacht
hätten, also ich weiß gar nicht was jetzt schlechter ist, ob die wirklich daran arbeiten
oder ob die nur sagen sie würden dran arbeiten und die leute verarschen, das ist eigentlich
beides schlecht, was fedora plant bios support zu entfernen nur noch auf uefi zu setzen, was
denkst du dazu, das ist eine bescheuerte idee, weil gerade im server umfeld teilweise es
durchaus noch daseinsberechtigung für legacy boot gibt, zum beispiel wenn du pxe booten
willst und es damit irgendwie probleme gibt und pxe boot ist im busses umfeld tatsächlich
relativ verbreitet, weil du halt da nicht mal einfach isos einlegst und ja in der heutigen
zeit ist es natürlich ganz cool, wir professionieren saggisch vms, wir deployen irgendwelche pods
in kubernetes cluster und sonst was, aber was die leute immer wieder vergessen und ich
hab geguckt es könnte mich mal interessieren wie ihr das seht, aber ich glaube das vergessen
tatsächlich viele cloud natives heutzutage, irgendwo in irgendeinem rechenzentrum steht
immer noch irgendein server im rack der irgendwann mal installiert werden will, da kannst du
noch so viele cloud services obendrauf packen, irgendwo muss das laufen und es gibt da durchaus
anwendungszwecke noch, dass man das auch ordentlich supportet, echte hardware ja, pxe kann uefi
ja pxe kann uefi, das kommt aber drauf an ob das in deiner infrastruktur ordentlich
funktioniert, weil du brauchst um pxe boot zu machen oder biosboot oder wie auch immer,
du brauchst unterschiedliche, wie heißt denn das, pxe files, uni files oder ich weiß gar
nicht wie der wieder knempel genau heißt, du brauchst unterschiedliche boot files und
je nachdem was du für pxe zeug verwendest oder was du für dhcp software verwendest sind
die teilweise nicht in der lage das richtig zu switchen und liefern halt immer das eine
oder das andere aus und dann geht halt entweder das eine oder das andere, also es kann durchaus
sinn haben pxe boot oder biosboot zu machen und vielleicht halt auch auf fedora, weil
es eben fedora sein soll, ne also ich bin nicht der meinung, also ich bin der meinung
das ist keine gute idee oder ich bin nicht der meinung, dass es sinnvoll ist das zu entfernen
ich finde das sollte man drinnen lassen, dass man jetzt da nicht so viel dran bohren und
schrauben und drehen will kann ich verstehen, aber ich wüsste jetzt auch ehrlich gesagt
nicht wenn das großartig stören sollte, ich mein ganz ehrlich im linux, gerade im linux
körner sind so viele tausend unnütze sachen irgendwo noch drinnen oder irgendwo dabei
oder sonst wie, da wird es ja wohl jetzt der support für biosboot auch nicht fed machen
nein ne ich weiß wie heißen pxe boot files wie heißen diese dinger denn, ne nicht wimp
files da müsste ich jetzt mal kurz in meinen router gucken was ich da eingetragen habe
ich habe hier auch einen pxe server laufen den ich quasi, also eigentlich Leute müssten
wir vms nie mit isos installieren ich könnte das alles über pxe boot und netboot machen
aber aus irgendwelchen gründen machen wir das trotzdem mit isos wahrscheinlich weil
schneller ist hat man ip dhcp server options options dhcp server ich bin zu blöd in meine
mikrotik router zu gucken wo man dhcp options überhaupt setzt keine ahnung irgendwo habe
ich gesetzt ja ich habe vergessen wie diese pxe u mikrotik schauen wir mal wie heißt
dieser krempel tftp folder ja geil super high res ne ne das meine ich ach ich hab keine
ahnung wie der kram heißt ist auch wurscht halt so pxe fall kann man auch machen ja deswegen
und gerade dass man die möglichkeiten hat eben so zu booten wie man will finde ich es
bescheuert das da raus zu hauen klar könnte man jetzt sagen ok fedora wird wahrscheinlich
in diesem umfeld eh weniger eingesetzt dann ist es hauptsächlich ja was ist es denn jetzt
sento ss ja auch nicht mehr hat jemand von euch schon mal rocky linux im einsatz gehabt
so als sento s ersatz das ist das empfehlenswert aber ganz ehrlich wenn es wenn es nach mir
geht einfach ubuntu server und gut ist hat dem sento es ja abgeschafft sich selbst abgeschafft
hat naja serverless unterwegs ja serverless ist ja die missverständlichste bezeichnung
überhaupt aller zeiten serverless ist ja überhaupt nicht serverless am ende gibt es
trotzdem noch irgendwas was deine webseite oder dein service ausliefert und das ist wer
hat das gedacht ein server serverless bedeutet im endeffekt du hast den server nicht bei
dir stehen im höchsten im besten fall im besten fall ja wobei ich mich nicht wundern
würde wenn es sogar schon die kombination gibt dass irgendjemand on prem serverless
lösungen verkauft was in der kombination ja überhaupt keinen sinn ergibt aber was
buzzwords kannst du die leute nicht aufhalten gucken wir mal on prem serverless gehts bestimmt
gehts bestimmt promises das ergibt keinen sinn aber serverless selbst aufsetzen siehste
geht schon los ich mein was sie damit meinen ist wahrscheinlich du hast halt letztendlich
irgendwelches container zeug wo du drauf deployst aber ein kubernetes cluster nicht
gleich serverless das ist eh schwammig deswegen bin ich kein fan von wildem buzzword bullshit
bingo ich mein genau so wenig wie ich jetzt mich hinstellen kann und sagen ok ich hab
Ich hab mein Frontend und Backend ins gleiche Repo gelegt und schreibt jetzt groß drauf
ich bin Monorepo Experte oder sowas.
Was hältst du von OpenStack?
Ich hab beides noch nie verwendet.
Es scheint mir für HomeLab aber etwas Overkill, es sei denn du willst einfach üben und was
lernen.
Wobei ich mir dann eher irgendeinen Kubernetes Cluster hinstellen würde, weil das ist das
was im Business oder im Enterprise Umfeld an vielen Stellen verwendet wird.
Allerdings eher aus Anwender Sicht ist es falsch, Admin Sicht trifft es auch nicht,
also nicht aus Admin Sicht Server aufsetzen, sondern aus Admin Sicht Server betreuen quasi.
Also man verwendet heute viele Managed Kubernetes Services, also dass man beispielsweise nicht
sich irgendwo Hardware hinstellt oder irgendwelche Sachen mietet und das dann selbst installiert,
sondern sagt man nimmt das Managed und deployt dann nur noch drauf und irgendjemand muss
sich ja da auch drum kümmern.
Aber OpenStack hat die Telekom glaube ich, ist die Magenta Cloud nicht OpenStack?
Ja, die Magenta Cloud ist OpenStack wo wir gerade dabei sind und von OpenShift habe ich
gar keine Ahnung.
Das Problem ist alten Code im Linux Kernel überarbeiten, generell das Problem Sachen
einfach mal im Linux Kernel überarbeiten ist, du hast vielleicht je nach Themengebiet
im Linux Kernel vielleicht eine Handvoll 5 Leute auf der Welt, die die Sachen ums dies
dann an dieser speziellen Stelle geht, du hast vielleicht 5 Leute auf der Welt, wenn überhaupt
bei manchen Sachen die überhaupt verstehen was da passiert und in der Lage sind sinnvoll
dazu zu Contributen, je nach Bereich, das wird glaube ich teilweise richtig überschätzt
so nach dem Motto ja Linux ist Open Source da kann jeder was machen, nein du machst nicht
so einfach, es macht nicht so einfach mal jeder was, außer vielleicht irgendwelche
Doku Typos fixen oder sowas, nö Google Cloud also ich kenne mich ehrlich gesagt wirklich
brauchbar nur mit Azure aus, Google Cloud habe ich verwendet allerdings nur als Teil
von der Google Maps, Google Routenplan und Google Maps API, das ist ja nicht wirklich
Google Cloud, das machst du über das gleiche Management Interface aber ich würde es jetzt
nicht unbedingt zu Google Cloud zählen, so und was ich quasi noch gar nicht verwendet
habe außer mal testweise Account erstellt und ich glaube mal die kostenlose VM gestartet
ist Amazon, stimmt Serverless wenn es gar keine Server gibt, das ist wohl richtig, Fax
richtig genau, das ist ja das wo ich mich unter der Arbeit auch so ein bisschen einkopiere
aber je nachdem wie du fragst heute hast du eh die wildesten Bezeichnungen, ich warte
noch drauf dass irgendwann mal einer einen Full Stack Bis Sack Dev Ops, äh, keine Ahnung
Clouds Engineer oder was auch immer sucht, einfach alles, das kann man auch machen ja
das machen wir bei uns auch teilweise, da bin ich mal gespannt wir haben so ein komisches
wackeliches VPN zu Azure und uns was öfters mal Probleme macht aber wir sind bei uns auf
der Arbeit eh nicht in der Lage das so wirklich gescheit zu machen weil die hauptsächlich
Cloud Entwicklung die bei uns passiert wenn die Leute sich wieder auf die Schulter klopfen
wollen und sagen ha ha wir sind jetzt in der Cloud ist nicht etwa weil die das sinnvoll
neu entwickelt oder sinnvoll umprogrammiert haben dass es jetzt ordentlich auf Cloud Services
läuft nein nein was damit gemeint ist ist wir haben uns drei VMs bei Azure gemietet
und haben den gleichen Scheiß den wir lokal haben jetzt in VMs und dann freuen sie sich
wir sind jetzt in der Cloud jawoll geil das ist halt nicht so im Sinne des Erfinders
und wenn ihr mich fragt finde ich auch ein Managed Kubernetes Service ist nur, sagen
wir mal Cloud also die Cloud Lite Variante ist man nimmt einfach das was man lokal hat
und schiebt das in eine VM bei irgendeinem Cloud Anbieter das ist im Prinzip kein Unterschied
zur lokal außer dass man die Hardware unten drunter nicht selbst betreiben muss so dass
dazwischen so quasi Cloud halb fertig, halb richtig ist wenn du dann irgendeinen Managed
Kubernetes Cluster oder irgendeinen Managed Service benutzt um deine Sachen aufzusetzen
und du gar keinen Zugriff mehr auf die Infrastruktur drunter hast oder brauchst und einfach deine
Anwendung da rein deploys das ist das nächste aber meiner Meinung nach das beste ist wenn
es geht und das geht halt bei alten Projekten schwierig das komplett umzustrecken aber bei
neuen wenn du es richtig machst dann verwendest du eigentlich Cloud Services um deine Anwendungen
zu betreiben nicht immer und nicht für alles es macht keinen Sinn alles jetzt irgendwie
in Functions oder sonst wo zu stecken aber du verwendest dann beispielsweise irgendeine
Managed Datenbank wo dir eigentlich egal sein kann was dahinter ist du verwendest irgendeinen
Managed Message Bus du verwendest irgendeinen Managed Serverless Functions Gedöns und vielleicht
den Kern der App dann irgendwo noch als Container deploit oder sonst was in der Richtung das
ist eigentlich das wie man das machen sollte wenn man neue Sachen entwickelt und unbedingt
in die Cloud möchte weil dann muss man sich auch nicht mehr um die ganzen Sachen unten
drunter kümmern weiß ich ob ihr das wusstet wenn ihr bei Microsoft VMs kauft in der Cloud
dann sind die nicht automatisch ausfallsicher man würde jetzt ja denken ja gut die stehen
aber Microsoft im Rechenzentrum die sind ja wird das ist ja Microsoft weiß ja wie das
geht ne ne das sagen die auch wenn das Rack ausgeht oder wenn die Wartungsarbeiten machen
oder sonst was dann ist deine VM mal kurz weg das oder deine deine wenn die Sache unten
drunter dann ist deine VM mal kurz weg das sagen die auch das ist nicht einfach nur
weil es in Azure ist jetzt irgendwie ausfallsicher du kannst explizit wenn du VMs und Sachen
in Azure anlegst kannst du sagen ob du das Rack redundant machen willst Standort redundant
machen willst global redundant machen willst das musst du explizit auswählen und dementsprechend
noch extra dafür bezahlen wenn du das machen willst das ist nicht einfach so wir erstellen
eine VM in Azure oder irgendwie sonst wo und das ist dann super ausfallsicher einfach nur
weil es jetzt in der Cloud ist ne ne so einfach ist das nicht wenn du dieses einfachste holst
dann ist es ne VM die im Prinzip das gleiche ist wie ne VM bei dir lokal nur dass es nicht
bei dir steht ja das war wie gesagt das heißt wenn man es wirklich moderne Cloud Architektur
verwenden will dann verwendest du irgendeine nicht mal irgendwie ne Managed Datenbank in
dem Sinn dass du ne du verwendest quasi ne Managed Datenbank wo du im Endeffekt einfach
nur ne Connection String kriegst hier guck mal da ist deine Datenbank ja dann verwendest
du irgendeinen Message Bus in der Cloud dann verwendest du vielleicht irgendwelche Serverless
Geschichten irgendwelche Functions und im Endeffekt den Anwendungskern vielleicht noch als Container
du hast quasi keinerlei Management Aufgaben mehr für die Infrastruktur unten drunter
und wenn es geht noch nicht mal irgendwelche Skalierungs und wirkliche Deployment Geschichten
weil du einfach nur den Service verwendest du machst quasi wie man so schön sagt SARS
und ich meine damit nicht Corona aber da gibt es ja mittlerweile auch alle Abkürzungen von
SARS bis PAS mehr wir haben übrigens auch kennt ihr CAS Leute wer CAS nicht kennt ich
zeige euch das mal kurz bei mir auf Github Keck weh es ist Service wo ist wo ist hier
Keck weh es ist Service wo ist mein Repo hier also wer CAS nicht kennt Keck weh es ist Service
ist das nächste Millionen Startup es ist leider noch nicht so richtig leider noch nicht so
richtig in Gang gekommen aber das wird das nächste große Ding wir haben schon immerhin
ein Fork und drei wobei es einfach nicht standardmäßig auf Github ne ich glaube nicht ein Fork und
drei Sterne Keck weh es ist Service das ist nur zur Vollständigkeit das ist was was wir
im Stream gebaut haben um Hetzner Cloud Funktionalität zu bewerben weil easy money easy life und um
Ansible Zeug Deployment zu zeigen ich weiß es gar nicht mehr genau ich weiß gar nicht
was wir warum wir das gemacht haben zumindest letztendlich ist es ein Web Service der Keck
weh random rotiert das wars das Backend ist in fünf Zeilen oder so ja es ist bestimmt
alles schon besetzt es gibt bestimmt es gibt es eigentlich auch Ars Ars oder Bas oder Zars
das das gibt es wahrscheinlich ach aber das ist wahrscheinlich e out heute nennt man das
wahrscheinlich anders wir lassen uns jetzt von LevelCapture baiten auf geht's also LevelCapt
was willst du erzählen genau almost everyone is still working on Battlefield Ars ist Arbeit
as a Service ja das finde ich gut also im Prinzip ist man nicht mehr Arbeitnehmer oder
Arbeitgeber sondern man ist jetzt Ars Service Provider oder Ars keine Ahnung gibt es eigentlich
gibt es Service as a Service ich meine es ist mit Software as a Service schon schon
Service as a Service Moment Everything as a Service X Xars auch Ears bezeichnet die drehen
echt langsam am Rad die spinnen langsam wirklich komplett ok LevelCapture Bait
wir lassen uns LevelCapture Baiten also angeblich arbeiten noch alle an Battlefield 2042 Keck
Bait dazu kann ich nur sagen Major Improvement sie werden drei Kisten auf Maps positionieren
ja wahnsinnig Major Huge wer hätte das gedacht dass ein weiteres Leute hättet ihr das gedacht
hättet ihr wirklich gedacht dass ein weiteres Call of Duty Game in Entwicklung ist ich nicht
das ist ja nur wirklich komplett nicht nicht zu erwarten gewesen ne das geht nicht
ja ja 400 Bugfixes da sind dann auch so Sachen drinne wie keine Ahnung so das kleinste vom
kleinsten ist dann da drinne so keine Ahnung Angel hat jetzt seine Mütze richtig rum auf
und sowas die haben übrigens bis heute das muss man sich mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen
Fixed Unused Import genau sowas ist damit drinne richtig genau sowas das erwarte ich
auch dass die auf 400 Changes kommen es ist ja ein Witz dass die bis heute nicht den Bug
gefixt haben das muss man sich mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen die haben bis heute
nicht gefixt dass die Leute in einem Shooter ihre Maus nicht mehr bewegen können vertikal
war es glaube ich oder horizontal es gab einen Patch der hat das drehen unmöglich gemacht
in Battlefield 2042 und das haben die bis heute nicht gefixt du kannst nicht mehr gucken
in einem FPS was man dazu machen musste ist dann man muss in seinen Settings Ordner gehen
und den Settings Ordner löschen und dann wieder neu starten aber das kannst du doch
dem normal das warum wird das nicht gefixt innerhalb von fünf Sekunden nach Release von
diesem Patch was ist das kann nicht sein du kannst doch nicht erwarten von den Leuten
dass die in irgendwelchen Settings Ordnern rumspielen die meisten der Leute wissen immer
wo sie einen Settings Ordner finden
der Trailer das muss man denen ja mal lassen der Trailer war das beste an Battlefield 2042
und man hat ja gedacht Leute wie ging das euch könnt ihr noch könnt ihr euch noch an
diesen Irish an diesen Irish Trailer erinnern an diesen Irish Story Trailer mit dem Schiff
und und sonst was das war zwar relativ platt oder es war berechenbar aber es hat mich persönlich
ein bisschen erinnert an das was Blizzard mit Overwatch gemacht hat die haben ja auch teilweise
so Kurzfilme rausgebracht und ich dachte eigentlich dass die quasi versuchen die Story weil Battlefield
2042 ein reines Multiplayer Game ist dass sie versuchen die Welt und die Story mit solchen
Kurzfilmen auszubauen aber außer diesem Irish Kurzfilm der im Endeffekt nichts für sich
alleine großartig ausgesagt hat außer dass Irish am Start ist kam nichts nichts ich dachte
da kommen jetzt alle paar Wochen paar Monate mal Kurzfilme oder so aber gut die haben andere
Probleme in dem Game aber so hat es zumindest gewirkt
also ja ich habe auch
weniger haare als früher noch falls sich noch irgendjemand anders foto erinnert ich
muss mal kurz kurz suchen ob man das das das das das foto noch irgendwie findet
hier das da meine ich
das da meine ich also das ist ja
das ist der takka boom rechts und ich links und man sieht das hier schon
das ist vor zehn jahren das ist vor ziemlich genau zehn jahren das bild
und man sieht es hier schon da guckt es schon durch an manchen stellen ja da guckt schon durch
und ihr könnt euch vorstellen mittlerweile ist da deutlich weniger an der stelle
ja prevent hair loss wenn du mit zwölf anfängst den scheiß zu nehmen wahrscheinlich ansonsten ist
das ja das ist ich muss nicht zum doktor wegen haarausfall ich muss zum doktor weil ich
husten muss oder nicht wegen haarausfall mehr in richtung moonmoon nee so wenig ist es noch
nicht hat er eher vorne wenig haare ich habe eher hinten in der mitte
also ja ungefähr so sieht das bei mir auch aus ungefähr so dass das das kommt das kommt
glaube ich ganz gut hin ungefähr so sag mal haben die nicht eben hat er nicht eben gesagt
das was weg ist kommt nicht wieder warum gibt es jetzt ein before und after bild wo das angeblich
doch so ist photos really speak for themselves ja ja prevention is key in the suit wahrscheinlich
war da einfach mal beim friseur hat sich ordentlich kämmen lassen die start taking action in prevent
hair loss go to keeps.com slash level cap or click the link hast habe ich das das letzte mal
auch schon gesagt ja ja ist ja auch widersprüchlich es fang eps.com slash level cap all right getting
back to this developer talking about almost everyone working on 2042 be a bro and tell
the community how many people are working on battlefield 2042 almost everyone ja gut
almost everyone von wie viel wenn man mal 400 waren jetzt noch fünf übrig
gespannt 2042 ich meine das ding ist im arsch da wird sich nie was tun so wie ich im letzten
video gesagt habe die wirken auch die maps und stellen fünf neue kisten in the works
was das spiel ist ein halbes jahr alt und es ist in der zeit nichts passiert in the works
das erzählen die uns nach den event die erzählen uns wenn die nächsten zwei battlefields raus
gekommen sind erzählen die uns wahrscheinlich immer noch jaja battlefield 2042 da sind
verbesserung und changes in the works ja genau das ist so eine shit show dieses ganze ding
ja das wissen wir ja das wissen wir ja dass dieses jahr modern warfare also dass dieses
jahr modern warfare 2 2 rauskommt also es kommt dieses jahr das zweite modern warfare 2 raus
und wer findet dass das bescheuert klingt dem muss ich recht geben ich finde es auch
bescheuert aber gut das hat sich so gut verkauft das reboot von 2019 das war klar dass man
darauf aufsetzt ja
klaus
Der map ist based in die godzilla und king kong was
Machen die jetzt auf fortnite oder was was
Okay, which lines up perfectly with that metaverse setting throwing massive monsters into the mix
Will surely put some ich mein vielleicht für zombies oder so
back into caldera
CD projekt reds latest financial call confirmed that the first expansion for cyberpunk 27 is delayed
Da sind die guter gesellschaft nothing specific about the expansion was shared however leaks suggest it will massively
Expand the game erkennt meine meinung zu verschiebe zu zu verschiebung im game umfeld ich finde das eigentlich in der regel immer sinnvoll
Sachen zu verschieben wenn es dazu dient dass es eben in besserer qualität und und fertiger und ja besser rauskommt
area with new enterable
Battlefield 224 machen soll ich fürchte ohne scheiß leute selbst
Ein jahr verschiebung hätte battlefield 2042 zu keinem guten game gemacht weil die sind ja so
Überzeugt von ihrem shit was wir auch in den twitter messages teilweise siehst die danach release und so rausgefallen raus rausgehauen
Wollt also die haben es die haben es nicht durch zeit mangel schlecht designt sicherlich auch aber nicht nur
Die waren auch davon überzeugt dass das beschissene design das richtige ist
Weil die nuke vor einfach hat sie verschiebung nicht gebraucht ja das ist ja im prinzip auch nie
erschienen bis dann
Gearbox mal gesagt hat wir nehmen diesen haufen
heißer
Unfertigen müll und stricken irgendwie was fertiges daraus und dann war es ja noch nicht mal sonderlich gut
Und fixing in quality of life improvements. They confirmed that content is still coming
But will just take longer than expected cd project red also announced that the development of the next-gen upgrade for the witcher 3 will be
Handled in house initially development was a source to
Blöde frage next das habe ich jetzt schon ein paar mal ich habe mich nie mit teil damit beschäftigt
next-gen upgrade von witcher 3
Ist nicht die pc version eigentlich seit release
Quasi next-gen irgendwie ich meine du kannst die pc version mega krass modden
Vielleicht nicht ins nicht auf skyrim level aber du kannst die schon ziemlich ziemlich heftig modden
Oder wollen die da wirklich
Oder wollen die da wirklich was überarbeiten also bringen die quasi einfach nur witcher 3 noch mal neu raus mit
mehr features aus der pc version sagen wir mal mit höhere auflösung
Bisschen besseren textur ein bisschen mehr fps und sonst was so wie es auf dem pc schon immer ist
Oder überarbeiten die das wirklich
also machen die
bessere npc models zum beispiel weil gerade die null und die feldwald und wiesen npcs in witcher 3
Wiederholen sich öfters und sehen für heutige verhältnisse jetzt auch nicht mehr taufrisch aus
Das wäre natürlich cool, wobei das mit mods schon geht
The studio behind the nintendo switch conversion of the witcher 3 no man sky
Received its latest major expansion this week called outlaws the dlc
immer noch starship also das muss ich habe mir normal sky übrigens gekauft auf steam letztens zwar glaube ich ja das war glaube letztens im angebot
Weißt du was ich kaufe mir das jetzt einfach mal und gar nicht so sehr
Weil ich das jetzt unbedingt spielen will sondern weil ich mir gedacht habe wenn das im angebot ist
Kaufte das einfach mal erstens vielleicht willst es ja doch mal spielen und zweitens weil ich es gut finde
dass wenigstens einer
Noch aus ihrem am anfang nur kann man das jetzt besser nicht mehr schön reden aus ihrem anfänglichen ziemlich verkackten game
Was über jahrelang supporte das ziemlich gutes gemacht
Hat wie viel kam es denn im seel ich habe keine ahnung mehr
Ich habe keine ahnung 25 euro 20 2 19 19 ich weiß es nicht keine ahnung
Ich weiß nicht nicht
Aber ich habe es mir gekauft
Auf steam gerade aus diesem grund und ich mir gedacht habe das kann man wirklich mal supporten
Und das ist der grund warum ich mir games kaufe
Und das ist der grund warum ich mir games kaufe und nicht weil irgendjemand von den entwicklern sagt so nach dem motto
Kauft eure games nicht im seil kauft eure games nicht bei key shop kauft eure games nur zum vollpreis
Kennt ihr den typ noch diesen ein fader war da von sony
Wie ist dann wie ist er noch mal
Das war von diesem von diesem zombie motorrad spiel der das erzählt hat ich habe keine ahnung es gab noch so ein sony exklusives
Es gab noch so ein sony exklusives zombie spiel wo man mit motorrad rum gefahren das habe ich nie gespielt zumindest einer der entwickler dort
Oder der chef days gone days gone genau hat doch gesagt kauft spiele immer zum vollpreis
Ja das ist halt auch so wenn er wenn er wenn er seine feuchten wunsch träume
Irgendwie in twitter sachen verpackt alter
Wobei war ich glaube das war noch nicht mal ein twitter post hat es nicht sogar wirklich irgendwo gesagt
Das war auch so ein ding wo ich mir gar fast mit euch los
Go contraband and explore all new pirate controlled spaceports
And while content will continue to roll out for no man's sky hello games founder sean murray stated that work on the studios
Next title is well underway
He confirmed that a small team of developers is working on an incredibly ambitious project similar in scale to no man's sky
He noted that even if a thousand devs were working on this game it would still be crazy ambitious
The game has no release window, so it's probably a long way off from launch
Halo infinites player count on steam has dropped to its lowest point ever from over
Die haben sie auch die haben es halt auch wieder richtig verkackt
Also man muss ja sagen ich fand der halo hat sich zumindest halt
Gut gut gespielt gut angefühlt im vergleich zu dem kram der in der gleichen zeit rausgekommen ist aber die haben es halt auch
Nicht geschafft die leute zu halten erstens aus sicht von vielen halo fans das sage ich jetzt nicht als halo fan weil ich
War nie großartig halo fan aber das was ich aus videos auf reddit und sonst wo lese viele viele halo fans
Waren wahnsinnig enttäuscht von der infinite kampagne
Und es ist halt nun mal so dass halo halt auch nicht nur das krasse multiplayer ding vergangener tage ist sondern viele leute einfach auf den
Die die mögen die halo story und den halo single player
und
Da waren sehr viele davon enttäuscht
Und multiplayer tut sich auch nicht so wirklich was dass er beschuldet
Außerdem warum ich keinen bock mehr auf halo multiplayer hat ist
Ich habe jetzt schon bestimmt drei vier wochen immer gespielt ist weil in dem game ist
controller steuerung so was von mega over tuned alter
also
Wenn du mit maus und tastatur halo spielst
Und ein gegner hier den berüchtigen ad ad ad spammer seit der links rechts seit der links nicht so schnell wir sind ja nicht in
Overwatch in halo ist es dann eher eher so
in overwatch ist
so und wenn das einer macht auf dem pc musst du deine maus nehmen und
hinterher eben wieder sich bewegt und versuchen irgendwie zu predikten wie wieder sich bewegt so
Weißt du was du mit dem controller machen musst nix
der controller bleibt einfach am gegner kleben
Und das ist also das ist also ohne scheiß halo infinite hat so ziemlich die over tuned ist
Der controller steuerung die ich je in einem game gesehen hat das war in alten halo teilen in halo 3 auch schon krass
gerade wenn du wenn du wenn du die sniper hattest und quasi direkt gestickt was aber so heftig habe ich das nicht in der erinnerung
1000 players launched you barely
6000 over the last 30 days because of this many players are going back to the master chief collection this cause the master chief collections peak player account
Ja wer hätte das gedacht die leute spielen lieber ein game mit viel content drin als ein neues game ohne content die haben ja bis heute glaube ich
auch nicht mal eine slayer only player list und die leute wollen halt team deathmatch team slayer only player list die leute wollen und vielleicht gibt es das mittlerweile
das letzte mein letzter stand ist irgendwie drei vier wochen her die leute wollen dann einfach rein team deathmatch spielen sagt der herr scholle
nö haben wir keinen bock drauf was interessiert mich was die leute spielen wollen ja selbst schon
it's this week the season 2 update for halo infinite launches on may 3rd and hopefully it'll help revive the game for players it offers new maps and
additional content players have been waiting for it based on new footage released by the developers the maps look pretty darn cool
the developers at ea motive shared another look at the dead space remake set to launch next year they showcase several clips of the famous plasma cutter and pulse rifle and
dead space 1 ist eines der besten atmosphärisch eine beste eines der atmosphärischsten spiele und eines der besten spiele in diesem ja kann man das genre
nennen in dieser richtung wenn ich es jetzt einfach mal die ich je gespielt habe keine frage das space 1 ist wirklich richtig gut was ich nicht ganz
verstehe ist warum genau muss man dead space remake das original sieht eigentlich immer noch relativ gut aus es ist nicht so als wäre das half life 1 graphics oder so also
dead space 1 keine ahnung let's play gucken wir uns mal footage an pc pc piecemeat ja meinetwegen so ist das ist das pc so wenn man sich jetzt mal die grafik an
ne das ist nicht pc das ist zu pixellicht das liegt aber schlecht auf das sieht guckt ne das ist nicht pc das ist konsole guckt euch mal die linden aber selbst auf
der konsole sieht das ganz brauchbar aus noch dead space pc max settings so das sieht doch ok aus muss man das wirklich remake das sieht doch absolut und gerade
der anfang sieht immer noch mega aus sieht das aus wie ein game was unbedingt geremaked werden muss
es ist doch es ist doch vollkommen in ordnung
ich weiß nicht warum muss das remake werden das kann man heute wunderbar spielen das sieht immer noch ziemlich gut aus
also keine ahnung ich war das verstehe ich nicht so genau aber ok
tweet the clips audio from the original game to the remake and then again to the remake
after implementing community feedback ea motive has been extremely open about the development
process of dead space even hosting live qa sessions and listening to players the changes
depicted in these latest clips are a result of that open communication zombie rpg dead island 2 might
actually release in the near future it was announced way back in 2014 suffered through development hell
the first game underwent similar treatment but has grown a massive cult following regardless a rumor
online suggests that dead island so was von nicht ganz ehrlich ein weiteres zombie game
brauche das wirklich kolyn moriarty of the sacred symbols podcast their sources claim the zombie
action game may get a new reveal and launch date perhaps the developers will share more details
during one of the upcoming gaming events like the summer games fest but that has confirmed quite
con will be held digitally in august the event will feature tons of giveaways charity opportunities
and online meetups but that has assured fans an in-depth event will take place next year as for
what reveals to expect from the event proper starfield gameplay fallout 76 updates and maybe a quake
remaster seems pretty likely oh nein hey rumor leute blieb warum wird alles remastered
warum muss alles remastered werden alter suggest the new need for speedgame will have anime elements
die sache ist jetzt mal jetzt mal ehrlich quake 1 und 2 die werden auch als remaster nicht in
die aktuelle zeit passen quake 1 und 2 sind eindeutig das soviel das bewegt hat fps technisch
passen die gameplay technisch nicht mehr in die heutige zeit heute willst du keine verwinkelten
korridore und keycards mehr suchen und nicht wissen wo du lang musst und und also das ist
gameplay technisch für leute in meinem alter die finden das immer noch nice aber ich denke nicht
dass quake 1 und 2 auch mit einem remaster auf einmal gameplay technisch in die heutige
zeit passen würden quake 3 ist ja komplett anderes game gab es quake 4 eigentlich ich
bilde mir ein dass es quake 4 gab aber das ist hat nicht wirklich eingeschlagen ja genau
das hat keinen wirklich interessiert popschutz 1 ich habe meinen popschutz drauf ich habe
einen richtig fetten selbstgebauten popschutz drauf er sagt dass das nächste game in der
franchise exklusiv werden und anime wie ästhetik mit anime style highlights werden aber es
wird den realistischen look von passen titeln erhalten die game ist in lakeshore city die
developers in chicago haben ich das gerade richtig verstanden das nächste need for speed hat anime
cutscenes habe ich das richtig heißt dass habe ich das gerade richtig gehört aber er will retain
die realistic look of past game in the franchise will be next gen exklusive and feature anime
like aesthetics with anime style highlights aber er will retain die realistic look of past
titles apparently the game is set in lakeshore city the developers take on chicago before we
get to our final story what do you think of the proposed improvements coming with update for
nix da passiert nix also es passiert nix und es wird auch nix ändern more substantial updates
playstation unveiled their upgraded virtual reality headset back in january this year it
boasts a refreshed design along with improved specs and visual quality however supply chain
analyst ross young took to twitter saying it might get delayed to next year the issue might be the
a.m. oled displays used in the new cr headset there doesn't appear to be enough of them to meet demand
sony has made no official comment regarding such a delay they also haven't announced a specific
release date for the playstation vr2 and therefore this weekend gaming as always guys thank you so
much for watching and i'll see you next time this is manchmal ist das merkwürdig was das
gehirn aus text macht hier steht gtfo is so brutal so und ich habe nicht dahin geguckt ich
habe das nur im augenwinkel gesehen wisst ihr was ich gelesen habe otto otto ist so brutal was hat
hä deutsche otto land was was hat das mit otto zu tun gtfo nicht otto das ihr seht manche sachen
nur aus dem augenwinkel und dann macht euer hirn daraus sachen die gar nicht da sind so was gucken
wir uns als nächstes an bitte bitte noch einmal nice ok excellent denn du darf dankeschön für
den subplot ich habe die hälfte übersehen moment hier mal kurz in die in das creator dashboard
das creator dashboard sagt
ansonsten noch keiner subscribt alles klar da habe ich auch nichts übersehen als ob
bettel viel schon genug updates für 4.0 bekommen hat ja das ist aber wie realitätsfern die ganzen
leute mal da ist so sind der wahnsinn was wie stehst du eigentlich zu einer kampagne bei gott
und bettel viel ich fand ja das sollte sein sollte sein letztendlich spricht es auch viele
leute an ganz ehrlich man sagt immer so schön und einfach single play interessiert mich nicht ich
hole das nur für multiplayer und das mag vielleicht richtig sein für die leute die das sagen
aber für viele leute ist ein single player tatsächlich ein verkaufsargument und mich
würde nicht wundern wenn ein großteil der leute sich die spiele kauf kaufen was die kaufen sich
die spiele spielen single player und spielen nie den multiplayer das kann ich mir gut vorstellen
ich meine wir haben keine statistik dazu man könnte sich vielleicht über steam ableiten
wenn man multiplayer zahlen hätte dass man in steam guckt wie viele leute sind und wie viele
leute sind die multiplayer eingeloggt aber seit black ops 1 gibt es ja glaube ich gar keine
anzeige mehr wie wie lange wie viele multiplayer eingeloggt sind aber da gibt es bestimmt viele
die das kaufen und single player spielen wie die multiplayer anrühren weil es ist immer noch so
dass für viele leute multiplayer ist zu stressig die wollen kein multiplayer spielen das ist finden
die zu stressig allein schon dass du gegen andere echte spieler spielst ist den zu zu nerven auf
reibend billing 90 style ab sp nein das habe ich miterlebt das will ich gar nicht selbst bauen das
reddit plays video ist gut was wie deutschland er plays domini 37 minuten alda das kuck ich mir
jetzt nicht an sprich deutsch du ja das passt dass das kann dass das ist so eine typische
geschichte dass das ist das kann ich mir wunderbar vorstellen dass das irgendwelche deutsche auf dahin
malen das ist so typischer das passt einfach sprich deutsch tun sie dieser chat ist jetzt deutsch
und dann muss man dieses passende emote drunter posten wo ich keine ahnung habe wie es heißt
genau dat cheffi genau ich kenne ich ich weiß ich bleibe keine ahnung warum die leute dieses
emote mit mit dieser chat ist jetzt deutsch in verbindung bringen aber das posten sie immer
vielleicht gucken wir uns das noch an aber aber ganz ehrlich 37 minuten ist mir jetzt ein bisschen
zu lang was haben wir dann sonst noch zu bieten big server rack unix smart home devices 8 hidden
windows tools ok das ist jebait video leute wetten das meiste ist blödsinnig ist das nicht
der gleiche typ den wir das letzte mal geguckt haben der uns erzählen wollte was wollte der
uns das letzte mal erzählen wenn windows acht nicht richtig runter gefahren wird wenn windows
10 windows 10 fährt nicht richtig runter oder irgendwie sowas wollte der uns doch das letzte
mal erzählen da hat er über acht minuten sich darüber ausgelassen dass windows 10 nicht
richtig runter fährt wenn du nur shutdown drückst und die option dafür nicht deaktiviert
hast bewertung ist schon mal nice naja ok wir schauen uns mal wir lassen uns wir können
uns jetzt an welche hidden schätze hier in windows auf uns warten da kommt jetzt wahrscheinlich
sowas wie die service wisst ihr wisst ihr was für schätze in windows windows noch noch
drin sind das alte control panel zum beispiel das ist nicht verkehrt damit kann man tatsächlich
mal was anfangen warum sind die immer so pumped und hyped wenn die videos machen alle so unnatürlich
pumped und hyped das kann ich mir nicht angucken leute
das halte ich nicht aus das halte ich nicht aus
ernsthaft der zeigt das fucking leute ich schwöre ich schwöre auf meine desktop pcs oder
ich habe das nicht vorher angeguckt
es sieht aus wie windows ui design von 2003 aber immerhin noch besser als uwp
er ist ja schön wenn die software ok ok dann habe ich was wo drin steht software has stopped
working und weiter was mache ich dann dann weiß ich ja schön
das gibt's halt windows 98 oder so
ok wir skippen das mal ok was haben wir als notepad das notepad ist natürlich krass hinten
wieso schreit er so das weiß ich nicht das machen das ist das das muss man im youtube
meta wohl so machen es ist ja auch es ist ja auch out ja also wenn ich ein video anfange
mit hallo leute ist da mags heute gucken wir uns das das ist das ist out eigentlich musst
du sagen leute was geht der max ist wieder am start und heute habe ich das ultra lustigste
spiel an der zeit also so musst du normalerweise videos anfangen dass die ganze zoomer generation
dran bleibt aktuell sind meine videos was das angeht nicht ansprechend genug das weiß
ich selbst aber ich habe keinen bock immer so auszurasten beim video anfangen weil sich
das einfach für mich nicht nach normal anfühlen ja wenn dein mikro nicht dreimal übersteuert
pro minute bist du richtig deine videos sind nicht dein haupteinkommen nein zum glück nicht
kommen wir kriegen jetzt notepad gezeigt wirklich
Was?
Nein
Also
Chat
Das letzte was ich mache oder wenigstens ist
Batch
Scripts
Das ist unter meiner Würde Batch Scripts, Alter
Batch ist okay
Batch nicht
Once we've done that, what we're gonna do is click on save, go back into my task
Okay, da sind wir noch dabei
Was haben wir denn als nächstes?
Ich fass es nicht
Okay
Task Manager
Was ist denn der nächste Punkt? Der Startknopf
Was ist das für ein Video, Mann?
Task Manager
Gibt es wirklich irgendjemand, der das nicht kennt? Und jemand, der das nicht kennt, der das jetzt nach dem Video auch aufmacht?
Nee
Epic Privacy Browser
Okay, was haben wir denn als nächstes?
Eröffne den Explorer, ja
Okay, das kenne ich nicht
Das kenne ich nicht
Aber will ich das überhaupt kennen?
Ist das Memcheck nur von Microsoft?
Memcheck 86
Oder Memtest
Was?
Das gibt's ja nur wirklich seit Windows 2 oder so
Device Manager
Ja, das funktioniert überhaupt nicht, Update Driver da drüber, das ist übelste Crap-Funktion
Was zum Teufel? Seriously?
What the fuck, Alter?
Ich, ich, keine Ahnung
Was das, was mit dem Video abgeht
Also warum, was ist, naja
Aus meiner Erfahrung aber unzuverlässiger, das wundert mich jetzt nicht
Für Boomers, ja für mich quasi
Aber ich fühle mich nicht angesprochen durch das Video
Was ist der nächste Tipp? Genau, Calculator aufmachen, Hui
So, was haben wir denn als nächstes?
Unique Smart Home Devices
Okay, wir gucken das Video nicht
Wir gucken kurz, was das für ein Smart Motion Dimmer-Switch ist
Aquara Cube, das ist so ein Zigbee-Würfel
Wenn man den dreht, kann man unterschiedliche Sachen
Hast du dir schon mal Lohnt-sich-das angeschaut?
Ist das, ist das diese, dieser Channel, wo du so, wo du, wo du
Keine Ahnung, das verdient an Fachinformatiker oder so?
Dann haben wir uns ja schon angeguckt
So einen habe ich auch da, ist nette Spielerei
Power Strip braucht man nicht
Smart Switch für Kokona-Wohnungen, weil man mit einer Säge Löcher in die Wand schrauben kann
Plink Doorbell kommt mir garantiert nicht ins Haus
Die Shelly Vintage Filament Lampe, okay, braucht man nicht
Ein Sonoff-Switch brauche ich auch nicht
Vor allem ist es wieder Kokona-Switch
Alles klar, nice, zu damit
So, ein 90 Dollar Industrial Cut 8 Ethernet-Cable
Oder Ethernet, wie die coolen Leute ja sagen
Ein Ethernet-Cable, ist es das wert?
Okay, ich predikte mal den Ausgang des Videos
Nein, es ist komplett useless in der Regel
Es sei denn, man bewegt sich am Rande der Spezifikation
Dann vielleicht
Also, besonders lang oder was auch immer
Oder man hat besonders krasse Außenbedingungen
Man ist in irgendeinem Fusionsreaktor oder so
Dann vielleicht, aber normalerweise ist meine Prediction nein
Es hat keine Auswirkung
10 Meter länger als normal
Okay, und was ist normal?
Was ist normal?
1 Meter, 10 Meter, 30 Zentimeter, 0 Meter über WLAN
Okay, ich gebe zu, ich bin heute relativ negativ eingestellt
Den ganzen Videos über
Aber die Leute müssen ein bisschen konkreter sagen, was Sache ist
Wie kann man 11 Minuten über ein Kabel reden?
Da bin ich auch mal gespannt
Der hat sich das Kabel, also jetzt mal realistisch betrachtet
Soll ich euch mal sagen, wie das gelaufen ist
Nicht so, wie er das erzählt
Also unterstelle ich ihm jetzt einfach mal
Nicht so, wie er das vorstellt
Sondern der hat bei Amazon oder sonst wo gesehen, ach guck mal
Die haben mal 90 Dollar Cat 8 Industrie Krate Ethernet Kabel
Und da hat er sich gedacht, daraus könnte man ein ziemlich cooles Video machen
Und dann hat er sich gedacht, wie stricke ich daraus jetzt ein Video?
Von wem? Ich brauche das für daheim und sowas
Ja, es ist ziemlich dick
Okay, seriously
Wenn ich einen Computer hätte, der meinen Desktop Arbeitsrechner
Der über Jahre random Disconnects hätte
Dann hätte ich schon Netzwerkkarten getauscht, Kabel getauscht, Router getauscht
Ihr glaubt nicht, ich hätte schon alles, das hätte ich mir bestimmt nicht jahrelang angeguckt
Und wahrscheinlich hätte ich sogar meinen kompletten Desktop in der Zwischenzeit getauscht
Und das Kabel hätte ich garantiert auch schon getauscht
Über Jahre hinweg random Disconnects, ich glaube es geht los
Und ja, Chat, ihr habt recht, in der Regel hat das mit dem Kabel nichts zu tun
Ich hatte das schonmal, ich hatte das schonmal, ich kann euch erzählen, woran das gelegen hat
Ich hatte das schonmal, und zwar, da habe ich ein
Da habe ich so ein Ding verwendet, an der Gegenstelle
Hier, das ist ein SFP Plus auf RJ45 Stecker
Und aus irgendwelchen Gründen, warum auch immer die Seite so kacke aussieht gerade
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen, war das Ding der Meinung, der Port ist ab und zu mal down
Ja, es könnte sein, dass ich das mit dem Ubiquiti Switch
Ich habe ja so ein, ich habe ja ein ES16XG 10 Gigabit Switch
Das Ding, 12 Port SFP Plus, 4 Port, also 10 Gigabit SFP Plus, 12 mal, 4 mal 10 Gigabit RJ45
Und ich habe mit diesem Adapter ein paar dieser SFP Plus Ports zu RJ45 Ports gemacht
Die gab es mal relativ günstig, diese Dinger, nicht so teuer, wie sie jetzt sind
Und der Port hat sich permanent hoch und runter gefahren, so random zwischen 2 Stunden und einer halben Stunde oder so
Und das lag wahrscheinlich an Kombination mit dem Switch, weil seitdem ich den geupdatet habe, gibt es das Problem nicht mehr
Das ist keine Optik, da kommt ein Kupferkabel rein vorne
Ich habe den Switch geupdatet und seitdem gibt es keine Probleme mehr
Das war eindeutig irgendwas im Zusammenspiel mit diesen Modulen und dem Switch
Typical Flux, danke für den Sub
Und lass mich raten, zufällig ist das Kabel natürlich daran schuld gewesen, was man vorher nie ausprobiert hat, seit Jahren nicht
Was für ein Ding
Was ist ein Split Pair Error?
Ist das, wenn man die, also in so einem Kabel hast du immer doppelte Adernpaare
Ich versuche mir anhand des Namens irgendwas zusammen zu reimen
Ist das wenn man die falschen Adernpaare vielleicht aus Versehen zusammen gewickelt hat
Ein defektes Adernpaar im Kabel
Das geht nicht, wie willst du denn das in Stecker kriegen
Ich hätte jetzt gesagt, das ist wenn man die falschen Kabel zusammen wickelt und dementsprechend aus Versehen
Wobei du kannst es nicht falsch anschließen, du hast ja das Farbencoding drauf
Du kannst es ja eigentlich nicht falsch anschließen und dann geht gar nichts wenn es falsch angeschlossen ist
Okay, schauen wir mal
Zeig her
Zeig
Vielleicht liegt es ja auch überhaupt nicht am Kabel
Okay, Moment, Moment
Ist der Aufhänger des Videos jetzt nicht eigentlich hinfällig
Das Kabel scheint ja in Ordnung zu sein
Vielleicht hat das Kabel schlicht und ergreifend einen Wackelkontakt
Ja Tom Trick, sowas in der Richtung denke ich auch, vielleicht ist das Kabel einfach kaputt
Egal
Ey, der Typ sieht aus wie Florian Silbereisen
Kennt ihr Florian Silbereisen
Das ist irgendwann ein Volksmusiktyp
Ja, das ist ein Volksmusiktyp
Das Kabel ist wahrscheinlich einfach kaputt
Wenn du es in der falschen Position hast oder es wackelt, man könnte auch sagen so eine Art Wackelkontakt
Aber wenn man das über Jahre hat, dann probiert man das doch aus
Außer man macht so viel Gatchirol über das Kabel mit dem Stuhl
Dann geht es auch irgendwann kaputt
Darf ich mal zusammenfassen, wir sind 3 Minuten im Video und bis jetzt hat er uns erzählt, dass der Aufhänger des Videos eigentlich gar nicht existiert
Er hat recht
Und kriegst den Signal wieder raus
Übersprechen heißt das auf Deutsch
Was?
Ja, das sind auch wieder Ami Kabel, die nicht richtiges Farbencoding haben
Wer braucht schon richtiges Farbencoding bei seinen Kabel?
Ah
Cell Tower Interference? Was zum Teufel? Ich denke es geht um eine 90 Euro Kabel
Warum kriegen wir jetzt doch einen Exkurs über Funkmasten?
Also die letzten 2 Minuten geht es dann wirklich um das Kabel oder wie?
Das muss ich auch so machen in den Videos
Also ich glaube nicht, dass er seine Verbindung am PC verliert
Weil er irgendwelche Störsignale von einem Funkturm oder von irgendeiner 5G Station in der Nähe hat
Also, ne, das glaube ich nicht
Ja und weiter
Übrigens, wenn ich netzwerk Kabel kaufe, würde ich erwarten, dass die getestet werden vorher
Also wenn ich jetzt nicht ultrabillige China-Chinesen-Kabel kaufe, würde ich eigentlich erwarten, dass die Kabel auf Funktion getestet werden
Vielleicht, wenn die tausende Kabel produzieren, vielleicht nicht jedes einzelne, aber zumindest im gewissen Intervall stichprobenartig und sowas auf jeden Fall
Aber ehrlich gesagt, wenn es ein bisschen teureres Kabel ist, erwarte ich auch, dass das getestet ist
Ah, da kriegst du das Messprotokoll dabei oder wie? Na dann
33 Meter? Ne, feet! Feet! Okay, feet, 2 Meter
10 Meter? Das ist ja nix! Damit kommst du ja noch nicht einmal vom Dach in den Keller runter gescheit
Okay, ich glaube, Cut 8 ist normalerweise auch kürzer die Kabel, weil höhere Frequenzen, höhere Frequenzen in dem Fall, warte mal, Max Länge
30 Meter
Ja, 10 Meter ist 0,815
Was ein Schwachsinn! Also das ist ja wirklich eines der nicht sagensten Videos aller Zeiten gewesen
Wisst ihr was das Gute ist? Wenn ich am Anfang des Videos mehr Updates zu Battlefield angucke, dann bin ich immer besonders gut drauf für den restlichen Zeit des Streams
Und finde jedes Video, was wir gucken, scheiße
Jetzt hast du ja so aufgefallen, wenn wir mit Battlefield News starten, bis jedes Video nachkann
Was hat denn der Auer? Der macht immer gute Videos
Gutes Gehäuse oder doch nur ein teures Katzenbett? Ja, juckt mich jetzt nicht so
Das Rechtzentrum haben wir schon geguckt, hat schon mal einen Senf zu abgegeben
Hast du eine Frage? Markus, kannst du jetzt erstmal live eine dicke Bong rauchen?
Chat was sagt ihr, soll ich live jetzt eine dicke Bong rauchen?
Ja bitte, dafür sein dachte ich mir schon gerade
Also ich hab keine Bong da, was haltet ihr von erstmal eine Runde Lötdämpfe reinziehen?
Also ich hab keine Wasserpfeife oder so am Start, aber so eine Runde Lötzchen schmelzen und einatmen
Nur die mit Pley, ja klar natürlich hab ich Lötzchen mit Pley, Lötzchen mit Pley fließt besser und schmilzt besser
Lötdämpfe, Gatschi-Bass
Oder wir fahren zum Frankfurter Hauptbahnhof
Natürlich ist das ungesund, würde ich auch nicht empfehlen Leute
Das war nicht, für alle die es nicht mitbekommen, das war nicht ernst gemeint Chat
Lötdämpfe sind zwar jetzt nicht ultra schädlich, also du stirbst da nicht instant von
Und irgendwelche Pley-Vergiftungen wirst du wahrscheinlich bei der Menge auch nicht kriegen
Aber du kriegst Kopfweh von, du kannst irgendwie Entzündung im Hals kriegen und so, das ist nicht schön, das will man nicht
Von Lötdämpfen, da hab ich meine Zweifel, dass man da von einen Großen kriegt
Wenn du zu viel Lötdämpfe inhalierst, fällt der dir vielleicht ab eher
Ich glaube auf die Größe hat das wenig Auswirkungen
So, gibt es jetzt irgendein gescheites Video, was wir mal gucken können
Ok, Server-Rack, ok, Server-Rack, please, gescheites Video jetzt, gescheites Video
Jawoll, das ist ein Deutscher, oder?
Das ist ein Deutscher, dieser Chat ist jetzt deutsch, Leute
Haben wir da schon geguckt?
Wir haben von dem was geguckt, aber ich weiß nicht, ob es das war
Haben wir das schon geguckt? Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher
Ja
Ja, ja, ja, ja, das haben wir schon geguckt
Ja, genau, ja, ja, ja, ja, ich erinnere mich
Das ist ja auch vom Januar
Oder?
Ja, ja, ja, ja, das kenne ich, das haben wir schon gesehen
Tja, ok, da war es das jetzt mit gescheiten Videos
Ach, war das doch was anderes? Sponsor Sophos Hardware Firewall, war das doch was anderes?
Ok, mal kurz, was hat er in seinem Rack drin, zeig mal her
Ok, was hat er für einen Switch? TP-Link
Ok, TP-Link 24 Port Gigabit Switch
Leute, wisst ihr was ich euch empfehlen würde als Switch?
Ein Mikrotik CSS326
Und die gibt es in zwei Ausführungen
Die gibt es in 24 Gigabit
Also das ist die günstige Variante
24 mal Gigabit, guck mal, 140 Euro, kannst du dich echt nicht beschweren
Die gibt es in 24 mal 1 Gigabit und 2 mal SFP plus 10 Gigabit Ports
Oder, ihr kauft euch den gleichen in der 10 Gigabit
Moment, es gibt, ah
Es gibt auch eine in der 10 Gigabit Variante
Das ist auch die Variante, die nur Switch OS kann
Aber ich habe vergessen, wie die 10 Gigabit Variante heißt, weil Mikrotik, Namensbezeichnung, MonkaS
24 mal 24 S plus
Den da, der ist auch sehr nice
Der ist auch sehr nice
24 mal 10 Gigabit Ports, SFP plus
Und für die richtig Hardcore Leute unter uns
2 mal QSFT
QSFP plus
Für 40 Gigabit
Das ist für die richtig stonks Leute daheim
Und das ist preislich nicht verkehrt
Das Ding wird verkauft
Also hier, für 499 Euro, da kannst du dich nicht beschweren
Da kannst du dich echt nicht beschweren
Das einzige, was dem fehlt ist, was ich cool gefunden hätte
Wenn die
Wenn die vielleicht der Achter Port Gruppe RJ45 Ports gemacht hätten
Da braucht man zu Hause einen Tonnen SFP Module
Nee, nicht unbedingt
Du kannst Direct Attached Kabel nehmen
Direct Attached Kabel gehen ja problemlos erst einmal bis 10 Meter
Und mit 10 Meter hast du das meiste ja erst einmal abgedeckt im Haus
Wenn du dann natürlich
Wirklich quer durchs Haus willst, über Patch Panel und sonst was
Ja gut, dann musst du dir was anderes überlegen
Ansonsten
Nutzt ja irgendein x beliebiges Direct Attached Kabel
Für paar Euro
Brauchst ja keine Module, geschweige denn Glasfaserkabel oder so
Ja 2,5G ist ausreichend im Haushalt, das ist richtig
Aber es gibt wenige
2,5 oder gar 5G Switche
Mit 24
Kennt jemand einen 24 Port 2,5G Switchen gescheiten?
Ein 24 Port ist schon nicht zu übertrieben
Ja und das schöne ist an den 10G Switchen, die können alle auch 2,5G
Und gerade mit so einem Ding fährst du eigentlich relativ günstig
Ja das dumme ist, dass sie keine RJ45 Ports haben
Ok was hat er denn hier am Start?
Ein TP Link, 24 Port Gigabit ja das ist so
Wahrscheinlich jetzt weder was super schlechtes noch was super geiles
Ein 24 Port Gigabit Switch
Also ist es sehr wichtig, alle Netzwerke in einem Server Rack zu verbinden
Also wenn du so ein Ding bauen willst, musst du definitiv einen Rack montieren
Es muss nicht TP Link sein, aber du findest viele Rack montierte Switche von vielen Vendoren
Und ich kann...
Gibt es?
Nein gibt es nicht
Ok weiter
Was hat er sonst noch?
Netgear
Oh ja
Wow ist das eine IBM Kiste?
Von der Farbe her sieht es aus wie eine alte IBM Kiste, aber ist es wahrscheinlich nicht?
Nee das ist ein Genpro Selbstbild Ding oder?
Nee das kann kein Selbstbild sein mit dem Ding da oben
Wahrscheinlich hat er sich einfach einen Server gekauft in alten
Ähm haben wir das schon geguckt ja?
Ich tippe mal, Boomer hier und hat es schon wieder vergessen alter
Ja doch
Wobei ich bin mir bei dem Video nicht sicher
Guck mal der hat einen guten Switch
Ach nee das ist das Mittagsofos Firewall
Ok das haben wir definitiv gesehen
Das haben wir definitiv gesehen vor 3 Wochen
Ja so sehr merke ich mir das nicht
Duck Duck Go Just Got Worse
Ok die Videos von ihm sind gewöhnungsbedürftig
Er sieht die Sachen teilweise noch übertriebener als ich
Und lässt sich dann auch teilweise über Kleinigkeiten 10 Minuten aus
Also ja was ich mitbekommen habe ist
Genau Duck Duck Go das habe ich auch letztens gelesen
Duck Duck Go oder gestern, gestern habe ich glaube ich auch gelesen
Duck Duck Go hat YouTube DL aus den Search Results entfernt
Und sie haben wohl auch russische Propaganda Seiten entfernt und sowas
War gestern großsehen nach hier
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen
Ich bin der Meinung das ist nicht die Aufgabe einer Suchmaschine
Den Content zu filtern
Was ist YouTube DL? Das ist ein Programm wo du YouTube Videos runterladen kannst
Wobei YouTube DL selbst ist out
YouTube DLP ist angesagt
Das da musst du verwenden
Hat auch nur läppische 23.000 Sterne auf GitHub
YouTube DL
Das ist eines der besten Programme
Hab ich das installiert?
YouTube DL? Nee YouTube DL
Install YouTube DLP
Sekunde ich zeige euch das mal kurz
J-Downloader
J-Downloader ist bei weitem nicht so gut dafür
Ich zeige es euch mal
Was da wirklich gut dran ist
Also ich mache mal ein Video von mir auf
Das da jetzt zum Beispiel
Auf installier mal
Ich habe schon eine Weile nicht mehr geupdatet ich weiß
Ja
Scoob ist ein Kommandozeilen Package Manager
Der ohne Admin Rechte funktioniert für Windows
Ok YouTube DLP
Minus ich glaube groß F ist es
Genau
Mit YouTube DL kannst du YouTube Videos runterladen
Und zwar ich mache es mal ein bisschen größer
Kannst du YouTube Videos runterladen
Da kannst du aber auch genau auswählen
Was du runterladen willst
Und das ist wirklich nice
Du kannst jetzt zum Beispiel angucken
Ok das Video ist verfügbar
In WebM bringt mir vielleicht nicht so viel
Container MP4 Codec AVC1
Das klingt ganz gut das will ich haben
Und dann suchst du dir das raus
Und sagst du willst
Download 400
400 ist quasi
2560x1440
In diesem Codec
So das will ich haben
Und als Sound will ich mir runterladen
Das da
Das ging mit YouTube DL auch
Ja nur mit dem Unterschied das YouTube DL an vielen Stellen nicht mehr funktioniert
Und YouTube DL auch getrosselt wird
Und das nicht
So jetzt kannst du hier runterladen
Und zack hast du relativ schnell
Das YouTube Video auf der Platte in einem Format
Was zum Beispiel deine Video Bearbeitungs Software frisst
Und das mercht auch die Sachen zusammen
Also sprich du hast dann am Ende nur ein Video File was einfach funktioniert
Hallo Leute hier ist der Max und heute gucken wir uns BattleBit Remastered an
Easy
Das schreit alle schon ein bisschen
So jetzt löschen wir das mal wieder
Also das ist ein sehr sehr nütz
Achso er wirft nichts in Papierkorb
Ja sehr sehr nicees Programm
Kann man empfehlen
Das Video müssen wir uns dementsprechend gar nicht angucken
Ja also wie gesagt ich bin der Meinung das ist nicht Aufgabe einer Suchmaschine
So Sachen zu filtern oder Sachen zu entfernen
Eine Suchmaschine sollte genau eine Sache machen
Nämlich Seiten indizieren und auffindbar machen
Was ich dann mit dem was ich finde was ich damit mache
Ist nicht das Bier einer Suchmaschine
Tja aber wahrscheinlich wird das gleiche erzählen
Ok ja was haben wir sonst noch für Sachen
I build 10 Web Apps in 10 verschiedenen Programmiersprachen
Ruby on Rails beste Leute
Ich hab's Jahre nicht mehr verwendet aber ich hab noch nie ein so angenehmes Web Framework wie Ruby on Rails verwendet
Sag ich vielleicht so als alter Ruby Fan der ein bisschen traurig ist dass Ruby nicht mehr angesagt ist
Ruby
Should you build your own router
Nope
Ok wir kommen uns das Lego Video an
Jetzt ich brauch jetzt mal ein Video wo ich weiß dass der Inhalt zum Titel passt irgendwie
Wieso nutzt niemand mehr Ruby
Weil die Verbreitung von Ruby hauptsächlich durch Ruby on Rails gekommen ist
Und Ruby on Rails nicht mehr so das angesagte Web Framework ist
Und deswegen wenig sich tut im Ruby Ökosystem
Was man auch auf GitHub gut verfolgen kann
Leider ich muss ehrlich sagen Ruby ist eine der schönsten Programmiersprachen die es gibt
Da hat keiner mehr Schienen verlegt
Doch die entwickeln tatsächlich Rails
Es kam noch erst vor kurzem Rails Releases
Es kam noch erst vor kurzem eine neue Rails Version raus
Ruby Rails kam erst die entwickeln die verlegen die verlegen noch weiter Schienen die sechser Version kam glaube ich erst letztens raus
Die entwickeln schon die verlegen munter weiter Schienen
Aber es ist halt so dass es mittlerweile halt eben Konkurrenz gibt zur damaligen Zeitpunkt
Zum damaligen Zeitpunkt wo Ruby on Rails rausgekommen ist
Da war Ruby on Rails wirklich Meilen weit ahead versus alle
Ich meine das waren Zeiten wo Leute Web Seiten in dem alten ASP.NET gemacht haben
Oder in PHP ohne Frameworks und sowas
Und da war Ruby on Rails einfach geil dagegen
Aber mittlerweile hast du sehr viele Alternativen und Ruby on Rails ist nicht mehr angesagt
Und dementsprechend ist auch die Ruby Verbreitung zurückgegangen
Dabei muss ich sagen ich persönlich
Reihen von der Programmiersprache
Ich mag die Syntax von Ruby viel viel viel mehr als die Python Syntax mit den Einrückungen
Es ist letztendlich alles Geschmacksfrage
Aber Python hat eindeutig gewonnen im Feld von dynamischen Script-like Programmiersprachen
Ruby ist nicht mehr angesagt
Da müssen wir uns nicht angucken
So und Lego
Ich will das Lego Video jetzt gucken
Da weiß ich nichts was passiert
Da kannst du immer nichts falsch machen
Moment ich lass mal die Musik an
Passt immer ganz gut dabei
Bam
Richtig richtig Korgas
Oh
Hast du noch Lego zu Hause klar
Ich hab mein ganzes Lego von früher noch
Mein ganzes Lego Technikzeug und Krempel
Hab ich alles noch da
Jetzt wirds aber advanced
Jetzt wirds richtig advanced hier
Was gibt denn das wenn es fertig ist
Will er das Glas hochheben gleich
Chat was mein dir was das wird
Will er das Glas hochheben
Ja das wird ein Greifer
Der will das Glas hochheben
Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal
Und das soll funktionieren
Pump pump pump
High IQ Zeug hier
So geht das jawoll
Das hatte ich bei Lego Technik früher auch
Diese Lego Technik Pneumatik Sachen
Die fand ich auch richtig geil
Und ich war richtig mind blown damals
Dass man an seinen Lego Motor
So ne Pumpe machen konnte
Und es dann damit auf und zu pumpen kann
War richtig next level shit für mich damals
Und
Nein nein es hält nicht
Funktioniert
Macht er da noch Fehler dran
Dass es weicher ist
Was gibt das jetzt wenn es fertig ist
Und
Max Power
Nice
Richtige
Fünf Kopf
Konstruktion
Jetzt muss er das noch weiter hochfahren können
Das hat er clever gemacht
Dass es da oben frei hängend ist
Dass sich das quasi immer senkrecht
Zum Boden ausrichtet das ist das ist clever
High IQ
Richtig cool
Jetzt reicht es nicht mehr
Oder
Wow
Alter was jetzt los
10 Subs
Max Power
Massive Subscriptions hier
Nice
Wer hat denn Glück gehabt
Scramble
Conditio Sin
Nee
Queanon das ist bestimmt
Lateinisch
Baumhaus
Oni
Mark Go Mr. Moogame
Bimmerzug Betai Goits
Zappend
Danke für die Gegifte in Subs
Pech für alle die gedotcht haben
Wieder
Hey es funktioniert nice
Ohne umzubauen
Oh das ist zu Schäpp
Oder
Oder nein es funktioniert
Oh das ist zu Schäpp
Oder
Nein es funktioniert
Das wird aber so nichts
Das muss jetzt nach oben noch ausgefahren werden können
Ich habe keine Ahnung was da passiert gerade
Aber er wird sich schon was ausdenken was am Ende klappt
Next Level Shit
Komplett Next Level
Kann es sein dass die Subscriber Sounds irgendwie nicht wirklich hinterher kommen gerade
Ich habe keine Ahnung was da passiert gerade
Alter
der sich was meint ihr ob er sich diese konstruktion einfach immer so aus dem ärmel schüttelt oder ob der da schon jetzt mal
einen halben tag mit beschäftigt ist oder einen halben tag vielleicht jetzt übertrieben an eine stunde mit beschäftigt ist
sich die immer die zwischenschritte auszudenken ich meine er wird mittlerweile die standardsachen schon wissen im kopf aber trotzdem
ist schon ist schon ziemlich big brain time es ist ein kran guck du mal funktioniert
ich habe gedacht bleibt jetzt hinten dran hängen knapp knapp aber es klappt nice
das kann er mit seinem kran bestimmt auch hochheben oder muss der kran jetzt noch
extended werden advanced advanced kran
aber wie war das lego darf man nicht sagen es sind klemmbausteine nicht dass ich lego verklagt
was gibt er das wenn es fertig ist
hi iq konstruktion ich kann euch mal folgen was es eigentlich gibt wenn es fertig ist live besuch
beim held den habe ich schon mal zufällig gesehen am südbahnhof ist er in frankfurt
hier bei mir um die ecke alter was gibt denn das wenn es fertig ist man
das ist jetzt aber schon richtig advanced kran was der da baut die musik passt gut dazu
also das da vorne ist halt quasi die schaufel und die schaufel greif ab das habe ich gecheckt
aber ich will dann dass es damit hoch geht 6 hat habt ihr das kommen sehen dass das so ausfahrbar
ist ich nicht ja na klar chat ihr habt das alles schon vorher gesehen natürlich boah mega
advanced kran alter soll ich euch mal sagen das ding könnte 1 2 1 original lego ding sein sieht
sogar noch ganz gut aus das ist ja mal hardcore das teil und jetzt ai trainieren das ganze lassen
ai plays lego autofahren twitch chat plays lego autofahren das das das jetzt noch remote
steuerbar oder so wobei das ist remote steuerbar da macht er da nichts dran krasse scheiße das
ist ja richtig cool mich würde nicht wundern wenn es real life sogar so was gibt nur halt aus
nicht aus lego halt das ist ja richtig nice more grip gib ihm ok dass das gummiband ist
bestimmt kein original lego und und und und oh wackel wackel wackel oh f
ok im prinzip geht es jetzt weniger um die konstruktion aber feinfühlig das ding fahren
kann oder nicht und abstellen nice also das das hat wirklich mal den eleven hat verdient
hier das ding ein hoch auf oberflächen spannung nice easy clap
nice nice das das das fand ich gut endlich gutes video heute hast du ein tipp muss für
die abschlussprüfung systemintegration lernen ja mach alte prüfung alles andere kannst du
vergessen besorgte die prüfung der letzten fünf jahre und macht die und wenn du die gut kannst
schaffst du die prüfung easy alles andere ist sinnlos es schafft jeder die fach informatik
abschlussprüfung der sich mit den alten prüfungen vorbereitet egal ob er ahnung von dem thema
durch also du kannst der geilste hacker mann auf der welt sein und auf eurer arbeit quasi die
konters komplette rechenzentrum automatisiert haben wenn du die iak prüfung im vorfeld nicht
gelesen hat gelesen hast verstehst du nicht was die von dir wollen umgedreht wenn du irgendwie
den den den becker leerling von um die ecke nimmst und lässt in halbes jahr fach informatik abschluss
prüfung lernen schaffte die fach informatik abschluss prüfung obwohl er eigentlich von tut
und blasen keine ahnung hat ich umgedreht nix gegen becker ja ich ich von seiner sache auch nicht
weil die iak prüfung sind so dämlich formuliert dass dieses iak deutsch wirklich nur sinn ergibt
wenn du dir ein paar mal prüfungsfragen und antworten dazu angeguckt hast gibt es eigentlich
mittlerweile ihk prüfung fach gibt es gibt es da ein paar übung wir hatten ja mal ein paar
übung sachen gefunden die perfekte ihk prüfung jaja wirkt wahnsinnig vertrauenserweckend
alter das problem ist hat er hier fragen drin also das problem ist du kannst die ihk prüfung zwar
im internet runterladen die sache ist nur die ich kann dir nicht im stream zeigen weil die
copyrighted protected sind ja gut der leerplan hat ja nichts mit den prüfungen zu tun die art
und weise wie die prüfung aufgebaut sind und die fragen gestellt werden das wird sich nicht
nix ändern großartig dran wie gesagt ich kann dir nicht zeigen ich kann ich kann dir nicht zeigen
das ist ja das eigentliche problem ich finde es übrigens das muss ich an der stadt ein absolute
sauerei dass man nicht die alten prüfung öffentlich macht warum nicht was vor was hat man angst vor
was was hat man zu verbergen bei der ihk vielleicht dass die ganze welt sieht wie beschissen ihre
prüfungen geschrieben sind und teilweise auch inhaltlich falsch anderes kann ich mir das nicht
erklären ja ihr müsst alte prüfungen euch angucken fertig aus nix anderes um die abschlussprüfung zu
bestehen und noch nicht mal sonderlich viel wenn du dir ein paar wochen lang immer mal wieder ein
zwei prüfungen die wochen anguckst woche anguckst reicht das dicke dann hast du nach nach ein paar
wochen hast du genug planung kannst du das
naja was haben wir ansonsten noch webapp ok gucken wir uns gucken wir uns was haben wir
ansonsten zur auswahl das haben wir schon geguckt world of warcraft documentary von 2006 allerlul
egypt travel das wurde mir vorhin empfohlen ich weiß nicht warum wahrscheinlich weil ich ab und
zu schon mal erstens video von denen geguckt haben oder so ich habe keine ahnung warum egypt ein
travel night mehr ist wahrscheinlich weil du gescampt wirst an jeder ecke oder ausgeraubt
oder beschissen wirst oder sowas du kannst spoilern hast schon gesehen wie lange geht das ja das ist
zu lang so wir gucken wir gucken uns jetzt wir gucken uns jetzt das webapp video an und am
mittag machen wir vielleicht ein bisschen progas progas stream wieder schau mal her fireship macht
mit mit eines der besten besten technik channels auf youtube
moment moment jetzt muss ich mal kurz gucken
hallo ich will zurückspulen was was hat er hier am start c-sharp gopeisen php ruby java script
chat was das das phoenix swift phoenix da steht es doch phoenix ist das ja schon da und das da ok
das ist java was ist das was ok das ist das einzige was noch übrig ist
elec elixir was ach das ist elixir das ist dieses ist das nicht dieses lisp ding dieses dieses lisp
java script zeug oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander er lang ja er lang stimmt er lang
nicht lisp er lang ja sieht da genauso aus
ok gucken wir uns das ganze mal an
das beste framework ist das beste framework ist das was für den anwendungsfall am besten passt
irgendwie sowas zumindest würde ich das als antwort geben ich mache zwar die meisten sachen
mit asp.net core was nicht aber unbedingt heißt das asp.net core für alles im backend die beste
wahl ist möchte ich zum beispiel irgendwelche java script libraries im backend verwenden dann
muss es noch es sein möchte ich irgendwelche go sachen für irgendwelche go libraries verwenden
dann muss es go sein also es kann sich je nach anwendungsfall unterscheiden präserief hat es
abgekriegt dankeschön max power ich will das aber wissen pock nein es heißt immer noch asp.net core
sie haben nur dort net core umbenannt in dort net nicht allerdings asp.net core asp.net core
hieß früher asp.net core und heißt jetzt immer noch asp.net core obwohl sie dort net core in
dort net zurück benannt haben alles verstanden chat microsoft und namen wir wissen wie sie es
wie kann man bei youtube dl die beiden dateien mördchen unter windows das macht er automatisch
du gibst das du gibst das so an guck mal du gibst das so an du gibst die formate an ich
weiß nicht ob es nicht eine einfache variante gibt du sagst format 4000 plus format 139 das
erste ist das video das zweite ist das audio und dann mördsche dir das automatisch zusammen
vielleicht brauche ffm pack das kann sein ja ihr habt recht ffm pack aber ffm pack habe ich
installiert deswegen habe ich das jetzt gar nicht gemerkt ok ffm pack braucht man noch
in different server side frameworks like rails django waterbell spring.net next.js phoenix rocket
jinn das ist ein go framework habe ich ja nie gehört meinst du eigentlich auch wieder du bist
aber heute spendabel oster überweisung ist reingekommen danke für die subs alle jetzt jetzt meine
güte hier 13 abos dazu kann ich nur sagen osterchamp ja huge subscriptions ok weiter
was ist das ist aber gut
gut jetzt es reicht vorbei danke für die subs gesetzt aber genug
das hört nicht auf 16 subscriber
jetzt aber leute jetzt gut grünsteilung für den sup
ich warte jetzt kurz bis ich das video weiter mache also chat falls noch jemand
subscriben will was übrigens immer noch kostenlos ist mit einem prime sub mit einem prime abo
warte ich jetzt kurz bis die subs durch kann ich das video weitermachen weil das schafft
meine boomer aufmerksamkeit spanne nicht das video zu gucken und ach du scheiße leute monka
es ich schaffe nicht das video zu gucken und auf den chat zu achten dass das angeht meine
güte hier max power nummer 10 abso es abso nene geht hier nicht um muskeln subs dankeschön
ab macaroni fahrrad rob am adonis adipos rush tv bus die ec ist sah sah schimmert nice
sie plus geil der kommentator und kalf am start hier mit subscription
ist gar auch noch subscribt eine güte leute das hebt ja mein subscription durchschnitt
hier vielleicht kann ich ja bald den neuen twitch vertrag aushandeln sage ich will mehr
prozent da reichen meine subscriber nicht bei ansatzweise für ok ok ich war jetzt noch
kurz und dann gucken wir weiter dass sie leid wieder am start dankeschön ich muss eigentlich
müsste ich öfter so sellout pausen mal gucken wir haben schon stufe fünf leute wir haben
schon stufe fünf vom scam train der wieder läuft kami dankeschön guck mal na gut die
letzten zehn prozent kriegen wir jetzt auch noch hin was heißt wir ich muss ja nichts
machen wobei doch ich könnte einfach subs giften dann ist es voll aber dann würde ich
mir quasi subs giften ist eigentlich das blödeste was man machen kann also von mir
für mich ich meine nicht wenn ihr subs giften wenn ich subs gifte ist das im endeffekt
ich überweise jeff bezos fünf euro und davon bekomme ich 2,50 zurück was bescheuerter tausch
ist ehrlich gesagt easy light kami der die das weiß brot mwd danke für den sub sub
continued game ab 140 prozent moment das geht über 100 prozent was ist das für einen
scam normalerweise sollte bei 100 prozent fertig sein deshalb ist es auch so dumm wenn
streamer um subs wettend ja da kannst du direkt bezos helfen wieder ins weltall zu fliegen
ihr bekommt nichts zurück von dem geld das ist richtig dafür bekomme ich was ab aber
wenn ich selbst ins abgifte dann ist das quasi ich verliere 2,50 kronk war mal bei 10.000
prozent krasser scheiß alle nähe ist es gut jetzt leute wir hören jetzt auf zu subscriben
vor das reicht genug subscribt genug subscribt so ja steuern kommen auch noch dabei von den
2,50 die bei mir ankommen muss ich auch noch steuern drauf bezahlen 100 millionen bits
poc so wir gucken jetzt das video weiter als genug genug subscribt leute haltet euch mal
zurück ne keine chance alle wo wolle subscribt oder giften 5 subs der renax hat wieder eins
gekriegt ja der hat ja das verdient er ist auf das da patrick auch noch medo king mann
der reus fast world problems ja richtig fast world problems gut jetzt gucken wir aber das
video da geht für den sub eigentlich ist es doch voll affig wenn man sich das mal überlegt
oder ich sitze hier sonntag morgen vor meinem rechner kucke mir content an den andere leute
produziert haben und bekomme dafür geld gut sagen wir so streaming in a nutshell ja jetzt
habe ich verstanden endlich wieder kram funktioniert mann ok das subtrain ist vorbei jetzt lohnt
sich nicht mehr zu subscriben jetzt ist meine güte noch mal 10 max power denn das ist der
name ist programm was aber zu spät der halb train ist der halb train ist vorbei dankeschön
für den sub wer hat was gekriegt humpen humpen sonn alles klar wenn du zu käme muss die
freak der ist auch öfter styling der name sagt mir was die nur zaurier ponkotsu da rex
tumeli ne tum lei bavarian reds apo 2g und der trainzug denn tu def auch noch hier was
ist denn jetzt grad los mann amax kriegt ein ebenster rob leake mave afrimas tron
da bist du auch wieder dange dann tun def so jetzt endlich mal das video gucken weiter
jetzt ich lese die restlichen subs nachher vorfalls jetzt noch was kommt base directly
into html for the ui together these three elements ich mag übrigens die aussprache
bei den amis in den videos immer html make up you controller architecture or mvc which
is by far the most common approach when building a full stack webapp the first framework will
look at is ruby ja nur mit dem unterschied nur mit dem unterschied dass der view heute
immer zunehmend durch kleinzeit javascript abgelöst wird ja model controller hast du
eigentlich in der regel immer noch aber der view ist meistens meistens javascript seitlich
small exes small exes moment du heißt nicht wirklich small exes point weil ich mich mal
in dem video in in in in dem stream mal einen small exes point hatte oder du heißt zu du
du heißt unabhängig so nicht wegen dem small exes point den wir öfters im stream haben
oder danke für die subs werden was kriegt himy an was geht net leader nüt nein nüt
twitch bom bom und innu und rion hat auch subscribt pochchamp
which is by far the most common approach when building a full stack webapp the first framework
will look at is ruby on race beste beste leute beste ruby on rails das war die zeit wo es
dann aufgekommen ist dass es dass dass ich leute als rockstar programmer bezeichnet haben was
ich ultra dämlich fand ehrlich gesagt was zum teufel soll ein rockstar programmer sein
ist for building some of the biggest companies in the world like shopify airbnb and github
rails was wenn es mir danach ist die leute die eins abgegiftet bekommen haben vorzulesen
dann mache ich das schnitt kam out because it dramatically simplified web development compared
to other approaches of the day it's still very popular in 2022 in des wobei ich sagen muss der
rockstar programmer den finde ich doof ich finde den brau kramer viel besser der ist quasi brau
und programmer which in space it has adjacent libraries like hotwire stimulus and turbo
that taken html centric approach to building webapps which goes against the approach you might see in
front and habe ich da gerade stadia gesehen eine strada nicht stadia fast centric approach to
building webapps which goes against the approach you might see in front in frameworks like react
angular in view to get started with rails you'll first need to have ruby installed and install the
rails gen and rails new i'm developing this app das war damals auch übrigens eine riesen hilfe
dass das war relativ neu das ist nicht so als als heute heute ist das standard dass jedes framework
ein kommando zeilen app dabei hat um eine neue app anzulegen mit basis applikationsstruktur das
war bis zum damaligen zeitpunkt nicht so das war damals richtig nice dass rails ein kommando zeilen
tool dabei hatte um neue projekte anzulegen channel hat eins gekriegt jetzt dann to death
dankeschön i'm developing this app on a fresh install of debian lennox and i did run into some
issues with the initial setup these were errors that chat debian oder debian was ist es bei euch
easily be solved with a google search but the initial setup was a little more error prone than
other frameworks once you get the project set up though the rail cli is extremely powerful not
only does it do things like serve the application with rail server but it can also generate a ton
of code for you automatically with commands like scaffold now if we look in the file explorer
you'll notice a bunch of different folders here and that's because rails is a batteries included
framework it handles your relational database das ist so ein buzzword das fand ich fand ich
witzig das war vor ein paar jahren mal angesagt da haben alle gesagt wir sind batteries included
postgres sagt das glaube ich bis heute ich glaube ich glaube postgres sagt bis heute dass
sie die batteries included database in unsere blödsinn testing logging and a bunch of other
stuff it might look pretty overwhelming your main application code is contained in the app
directory where you find folders for ruby struktur ich baue was die struktur wie ruby on rails die
app aufgebaut hat hat maßgeblich neuere frameworks mit beeinflusst guckt euch mal
irgendwelche x-beliebigen tools an das ist alles sehr sehr ähnlich aufgebaut
was ist die aussprache debian also ruby ist wirklich ruby sieht einfach gut aus ruby ist
so so schön lesbar und kurz und knackig also neben sie scharf ist ruby meine meine
abstand lieblings programmier sprache leider kann man so gut wie nichts mehr in ruby machen weil
es nicht mehr angesagt ist klar ich meine du kannst irgendwelche eigenen scripts und so was
mit ruby mit ruby bauen das ist keine frage aber es ist halt nicht mehr so richtig angesagt aktuell
was schade ist weil ruby ist wirklich eine schöne programmier sprache troller action user visits a
url it will trigger one of these actions on the server that action might go and retrieve some
data from your database the logic for that data is contained in the model but before we can use
the data in the database we need to run a migration which will take the code in the model and sync it
up with the actual database and all the data is managed with an object relational mapper
called active record and finally you have a view which is an html record das war es das kam zu
einer zeit wo die leute noch normalerweise raw sql geschrieben haben in pap mit sich
sicherheitslücken erb stands for embedded ruby and it allows you to render your data dynamically
inside und das klingt sehr monolith ja das ist so in ruby on rails tauscht du nicht einfach mal den
db mapper aus das ist halt so entweder active record oder pech gehabt overall das provides
a very nice separation of concerns and rails is very opinionated which means you can achieve a lot
rails ist richtig richtig richtig eklig sogar wenn du was tauschen willst rails ist sogar richtig
pingelig wie die dateien heißen müssen wenn die dateien nicht controller heißen dann funktionieren
sie nicht und sowas a little code the scaffold not only retrieves items from the database but it
also provides you why to create an update that data as well but too much magic can also be a bad
thing depending on who you ask and ruby is not the most popular language in the world leide leide
what if there is a way we could build web apps like this with python and that's where django comes
in it's also extremely popular and has been you ich habe noch nie was in django gemacht das einzige
was ich weiß ist dass django hat ein admin panel mit dabei das ist das einzige was ich da drüber
weiß und bitt bucket when you generate a new django app you'll notice the file structure is far less
overwhelming than rails but at the same time it's still very much a batteries included framework
tends to be a lot more explicit for example we have this manage py file that contains the code for the
actual command line interface to generate things in the project we could use it to serve the app
locally or generate an app to represent a feature of the website it also follows the mbc architecture
with routes being defined in the urls.py file and controllers are represented as python functions
in the views.py file a route ich meine nicht dass pyson schlecht lesbar werden kann man nicht sagen
die sprache ist an sich auch super aber mir gefällt ruby einfach einen tick besser these functions
which itself might want to access data from one of our models a model is a python class represents
the structure of data in an sql database aka the object relational mapper and finally we have our
html templates that allow you to embed python directly into the code that's pretty cool but one
extra superpower of django is that it has an admin feature built in ja das ist das einzige was ich
davon kenne. you can register them with the admin app to easily manage all of your data in the
browser this is really useful and not something that you'd want to roll out on your own pythons
great and all but the original server-side language of the web was php. there have been countless php frameworks over the
years and high level tools like wordpress but the most popular one today is laraval. laraval
ich dachte laraval aber okay laraval, laraval. laraval ist tatsächlich ganz wichtig. laraval ist tatsächlich voulais shaking app, insult a lot of app, it took a long time
and downloaded a lot of packages and as you can see the initial project has a lot of batteries
included, even more so than Rails. If we look at routes, you can see it not only handles web
routes, but also API routes and channels for real-time communication with web sockets. Now,
if we go into the app code, you'll notice it's already been configured with things like user
authentication via providers. A provider is like a shared service that you can use anywhere in the
application. In the HTTP directory, we will find our controllers, and just like Rails, we have a
class that contains a bunch of different methods that can access data and render a specific
template. Now, our database models use a tool called Eloquent ORM, which is based on... Eloquent
is the capital in Laravel. Yeah, I remember....PHT is a language that's designed to work with HTML out
of the box. Laravel makes it even easier by building on top of PHP... PHP hat immer noch einen
riesen Vorteil versus alles andere. Und das ist, dass auf jedem Feld, Wald und Wiesen-Hoster,
dass jeder Feld, Wald und Wiesen-Hoster PHP mitliefert. Du kannst dir irgendein 2-Euro-Strato-Web-Space
kaufen, und da drauf geht PHP. Da drauf wirst du weder Ruby zum Laufen bekommen, noch.NET,
noch irgendwas anderes. Aber PHP geht. Das ist immer noch ein riesen Vorteil von PHP.
Another cool point about the ecosystem is that they put a lot of thought into how to integrate...
Ja, wo ist der Stratl sein, Chat? Das könnte alles sein. Du kaufst irgendein billiges Webhosting-Package,
und es ist PHP dabei. Und nur PHP, sonst nix.
...works like React and Vue. It has an adjacent tool called Inertia that can bridge the gap...
Und wo sind wir jetzt? Wo sind wir jetzt? Laravel, okay.
...frameworks. The next framework we'll look at is Next.js, which allows us to build a full-stack
application entirely with JavaScript. In the JavaScript world, there's a million different
options we could have chosen here, like Nuxt.js, Angular Universal, SvelteKit, Nest.js, Adonis,
and many others. Maybe I'll make a top 10 video just for those. To get started with Next,
we run npx-create-next-app, and that will generate a starter project. Now, the one thing you'll
notice about Next right off the bat is that it doesn't provide any integration for your database.
There are a million different solutions to choose from, but one of my...
Ja, React ist das Gegenteil von Monorepo. Nee, ist das Gegenteil von alles in einem. React
musst du dir selbst zusammenstücken. Dafür hast du halt die Auswahl.
...favorites is Prisma. So I'm going to add Prisma to this project. The fact that Next.js doesn't
have a database out of the box is a good thing in my opinion. The JavaScript ecosystem is just way
too crazy. It's nice to start with... Ja, ja. Aber der Unterschied ist, du hast schon im Prinzip recht.
Das ist aber nur der Fall, wenn du was machst, was du selbst betreiben willst. Wenn du jetzt
vielleicht, sagen wir mal, ein Shopping-System rausbringst, wo du willst, dass es jeder Vollbop
benutzen kann, dann ist PHP gar nicht so schlecht, weil die kaufen sich bei Strato ein Webpackage
und schieben dein Shop drauf und gut ist. Die kaufen sich keine vm bei Hetzner. Also je nachdem,
was man machen will. Ich glaube, ich muss mich irgendwann mal mit React beschäftigen. Also Leute,
ich habe jetzt viele Sachen in letzter Zeit mit Svelte gemacht, relativ viele Sachen auch mit
Vue gemacht, auch alles schon im Stream. Angular werde ich mir im Leben nicht angucken, wenn ich
nicht vermeiden kann. Aber React habe ich mich noch nie großartig mit auseinandergesetzt.
Wie würdet ihr sagen, wenn man relativ gut zurecht kommt mit Vue und Svelte, wie kompliziert ist es,
in React reinzukommen? Was ich mitbekommen habe ist halt, dass das React-Ökosystem deutlich mehr
gestückelt ist als beispielsweise Vue. Schon was mit LoRa waren gemacht, klar,
sogar im Stream haben wir LoRa Zeug zusammengebastelt. Was, React würde ich abnerven, okay.
Next.js, ja, das würde ich dann wahrscheinlich auch nehmen. Ja, guck mal, pass mal auf, wir haben
noch jetzt ein nice Archive. Guck mal, LoRa, Low Level Zeugs und 1,5 Kilometer Datenübertragung ESP32.
Das da brauchen wir, glaube ich. Das ist der Anfang vom Stream, Alter.
Bester Stream Anfang. Ja, guck, da haben wir LoRa-Krempel gemacht. Und noch mal kurz das
andere schauen. Das ist aber schon drei Jahre her. Ja. React-Component hat im Durchschnitt
vier Prozent mehr Code als Vue. Die Component, die auf einen Client ankommt oder bei einem
selbst. Auf der anderen Seite ist es halt manchmal gar nicht so schlecht, wenn weniger Magic passiert
im Hintergrund und man besser durchblickt. Schwer zu sagen. Oder meint ihr, es macht keinen Sinn,
wenn man mit Vue und Vue ganz gut ist, noch React zu lernen? Ich meine, ich werde nie hauptberuflich
als Web-Entwickler arbeiten. Habe ich nicht vor. Dann ist natürlich sinnvoll, wenn man
React kann, weil das ziemlich verbreitet ist. Angucken kann man es, ja. Ich weiß halt nicht,
ob es sich lohnt. Okay, weiter. Leute, ich weiß nicht warum, aber irgendwie hat es mir
dieses Emote angetan. Das gibt es schon seit fünf Jahren oder so. Aber irgendwie habe ich
heute Gatschi-Roll mal ins Memboard aufgenommen. Ich weiß nicht warum. Mir war es so danach.
Moment, was? Was ist denn das? Was ist das für eine komische Syntax? Return? Ungleich
oder was auch immer? Was ist denn das in Javascript? Leeres Tag? Ach so, das ist kein Javascript
Syntax, das ist ein leeres Tag. Das ist quasi öffnender Tag, schließender Tag. Ach, das
ist JSX. Ah, ja, ja, ja, ja, okay. Template ist das quasi unter der Haube. Aha.
Das ist das, was mich an React ein bisschen abschreckt. Zumindest das, was ich bisher
von gesehen habe, dass es halt so zerstückelt ist. Da hast du irgendwie zwischen Prisma,
wo ich jetzt nicht mal eine Ahnung habe, was es überhaupt ist. Ist das der Datenbank-Mapper
oder was ist Prisma? Ist das jetzt das Node.js-Backend hier gerade, was ich sehe? Okay. Ja, okay.
Boah, Hilfe, bloß nicht.
Wo ist denn mein Java-Emote, Leute? Wo ist mein Java-Emote? Moment. Ich habe zu viele
Bilder drin. Sieht jemand meinen Java-Emote? Hatte ich nicht so eine Tasse irgendwo? Das
Teil, das kenne ich ja. Ich hatte doch aber irgendwo eine Tasse, oder? Oder hatte ich
es nur im Discord? Ah, hier. Okay. Ja, mit Spring gab es ja auch letztens Probleme. Ich
glaube, das gibt es nicht als Better-Twitch-TV-Emote. Welche Probleme gab es bei Spring? Es gab
echt eine Sicherheitslücke, wo die Leute wieder Remote-Shells bekommen konnten. Wurde
dann passend entsprechend von Log4j zu Spring4Shell oder so benannt. Java in Visual Studio Code,
ja, das würde ich auch tatsächlich nicht machen. Da würde ich IntelliJ verwenden.
Gibt es eigentlich noch irgendjemand, der Eclipse oder NetBeans verwendet? Oder mittlerweile
alle IntelliJ und JetBrains gedürnt?
Also ich finde Visual Studio Code suckt für sowas. Also ich vergleiche es jetzt einfach
mal mit.NET und C-Sharp. Und das ist offiziell von Microsoft. Also sprich, eigentlich sollte
man.NET und C-Sharp in Visual Studio Code gut machen können, aber ich finde es so hakelig
einfach nur. Ich mag das überhaupt nicht. Für Frontend-Sachen Visual Studio Code gar
keine Frage, aber ich mag das null. Für YouTube? Nee. Nee, nee, so. Guck mal. YouTube, also
hier. Y, T-, DLP. Das findest du auch auf GitHub, 23.000 Sterne. WebStorm, okay Leute, WebStorm
versus Visual Studio Code. Warum? Warum? Was ist besser? By the way, jetzt kommt mein Lieblingsframework
hier. Nee, Blazer ist was, wo ich nicht warm geworden bin mit. Ja.
Ein Nachteil, den man bei ASP.NET Core hat, den sich Microsoft aber selbst eingefangen
hat über die letzten Jahre, also selbst Schuld dran ist, du hast in ASP.NET bei vielen Sachen
2, 3, 4 Möglichkeiten teilweise Sachen zu machen. Ja, jetzt hast du Minimal APIs, dann
gibt es noch Fast Endpoints als Library, dann hast du Controller, also du hast Web API,
du hast Controller, die anhand des Namens Controller werden, du hast Controller mit
Attributen, du hast API Controller, du hast Controller Base, du hast normale Controller,
du hast komplettes MVC oder nicht, du hast Razor Pages, du hast Blazer. Du kannst damit
alles machen, aber es ist nicht so wirklich klar, welchen Weg man jetzt benutzen sollte,
das finde ich ein bisschen unglücklich von Microsoft. Ja, Razor Templates ist überhaupt
nicht mein Ding. Ihr wisst ja, ich mache sehr vieles mit ASP.NET Core als Web Framework
und ich habe noch nie eine Anwendung mit Razor Templates erstellt, noch nie. Ich weiß gar
nicht, wie Razor Templates funktionieren. Weiß nicht, ob es Leute gibt, die das verwenden.
Ich glaube, das höchste der Gefühle war, war mal, dass ich meine Indexseite als Razor
Template hatte, wo dann ein paar Daten an JavaScript Zeug übergeben wurden, aber ansonsten,
ich habe noch nie Razor Pages verwendet. Euer komplettes Freund, dann ist Razor Pages, ok.
Ja, ich denke mal, wenn man einen Plan davon hat und die Seiten relativ statisch sind und
die Daten, wie sagt man, data driven oder so, dann ist das bestimmt nice, aber ich habe
noch nie was mitgemacht und ich habe da auch ehrlich gesagt keinerlei Zug dazu, genauso
wenig wie Blazer. Blazer reizt mich auch überhaupt nicht, wobei ich ja als alter C Sharp Fan eigentlich
voll drauf ausflippen müsste, dass man jetzt C Sharp im Browser mit WebAssembly verwenden
kann, aber die Technologie begeistert mich noch nicht so richtig.
Haustet ihr eure.NET Sachen auch auf Windows Server? Nein. Also ich will nicht ausschließen,
dass wir Windows Server mit.NET Software drauf haben bei uns auf der Arbeit. Bestimmt. Aber
also ich, also sagen wir mal so, Software, an der ich beteiligt war, die läuft ausschließlich
unter Linux, die ich kenne bei uns auf der Arbeit, die wir programmiert haben. Wir haben
Windows Zeugs, ja, zum Beispiel für die Zeiterfassung und sowas, aber das ist ja alles zugekauft.
Und ganz einfach ist ja zumindest mein Zeug, was ich bisher gebaut habe, so an Tools und
vielleicht auch die kleinen oder anderen Webfrontend Übersichten oder sowas, das läuft exklusiv
unter Linux. Es gibt auch überhaupt keinen Sinn,.NET unter Windows laufen zu lassen,
wenn du es unter Linux laufen lassen kannst..NET Core läuft unter Linux mindestens mal
genauso gut wie unter Windows. Also warum sollte ich es dann unter Windows laufen lassen?
Doch, wenn du HTTP Sys laufen lassen willst. Ich weiß noch nicht mal, was HTTP Sys ist.
Ist das irgendein IES oder was? Keine Ahnung. IES, ja, LUL. IES. Hast du auch ein ODBC Treiber?
Tja, da weiß ich nicht, wie das unter Linux funktioniert. Letztendlich hast du mit.NET
Core noch nie irgendwelche Probleme. Du hast das eingebaute Entity Framework und du kannst
entweder SQLite verwenden, Postgres, MySQL, MariaDB, Microsoft SQL. Du brauchst im Prinzip
Benutzerdaten und Connection String, fertig. Um den Rest musst du dich nicht kümmern.
Also, tja, mag sein, dass es manche Sachen nur unter Windows gibt, aber ich hab sie zumindest
noch nicht gebraucht oder vermisst bisher und ich mache relativ viel.NET Zeug. Ich entwickle
komplett unter Linux und ich lasse die Sachen komplett unter Linux laufen. So. Oh, jetzt
kommt Elixir. Ja,.NET Framework ist Windows-only. Aber.NET Framework ist ja quasi der Vorgänger
von.NET Core oder mal was anderes..NET Core selber läuft ja seit Jahren schon problemlos
Cross-Plattformen unter Linux. Hä? Also, hab ich doch nie gesehen, dass es da Probleme
gibt, das zu installieren..NET ist glaube ich eines der unproblematischsten Sachen.
Ansonsten, wenn man Jaro nicht will, genau nehmen das.NET Installer Skript. Wenn du
es nicht, ach du willst das selbst kompilieren, ok, das hab ich noch nie gemacht..NET selbst
kompilieren hab ich noch nie gemacht. Und aus welchem Grund möchtest du.NET selbst
kompilieren? Also, muss ja nen Grund haben. Die Idee bin ich noch gar nicht gekommen.
Also das bescheuertste, was ich mal selbst kompiliert habe, war Chrome und ich hab dann
aufgehört, nachdem das Ding irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 120 GB RAM braucht und 50 TB Festplattenplatz
um zu kompilieren. Also, hatte ich keinen Bock mehr. Eine.NET Core App unter Linux
zu kompilieren ist überhaupt kein Ding..NET Publish,.NET Run, Self-Contain Publish, haben
wir schon so oft gemacht. Nee,.NET Framework ist 4.8, das bleibt 4.8..NET 6 ist.NET 5,
also.NET 6 ist die Weiterentwicklung von.NET 5 und.NET 5 ist.NET Core 3.1 der Vorgänger
gewesen. Also.NET Core 3.1 wurde quasi die nächste Version.NET 5 genannt. Die Microsoft-Benahmung
ist einfach für'n Arsch. Die App braucht eine spezifische.NET Core Version. Also
du kannst in der Regel, wenn du.NET 6 installiert hast, die Apps, die alte Versionen brauchen
ausführen. Was nicht geht, ist umgedreht. Wenn du nur.NET Core 5 installiert hast,
dass du eine.NET Core 6 App laufen lässt. Nee, das stimmt nicht..NET Framework, also
vom zeitlichen Ablauf ist das richtig. Aber.NET Framework hat nichts mit.NET Core zu
tun..NET Framework ist Windows-only-proprietärer Microsoft-Kram..NET Core ist Neuentwicklung
Open Source auf GitHub, die nichts, auch codebase-technisch, nichts mit.NET Framework zu tun hat. Das Problem
am Anfang von.NET Core war ja, dass viele wichtige Sachen aus dem.NET Framework gar
nicht unterstützt wurden und am Anfang wollte das niemand verwenden. So richtig verwenden
tun die Leute.NET Core eigentlich erst seit 2.1 oder seit 2.0. Hä, das muss eigentlich
funktionieren. Du kannst hier disinstallieren, aber du kannst normalerweise, also wenn du
.NET 6 hast, kannst du in deinem Projekt auswählen, was für eine Runtime- und Language-Version
du verwenden willst und das geht dann einfach. Komisch, naja. Da muss man sich die Fehlermeldung
mal genauer machen. Wir sind jetzt schon ewig zu Gange bei diesem Video, Alter. Alter, das
ist für die ganzen, boah, Alter, was zum Teufel ist das für eine Sündtags? What the fuck?
Da müsste ich ja jedes Mal auf meine Tastatur gucken, dass ich sowas schreiben könnte.
Das ist Massive Functional. Erinnert mich ein bisschen an Bash Pipes, oder? String-LXL
gepiped nach String-Crafemes, gepiped nach innenen Frequencies. Boah, nee, das ist aber,
da müsste ich mich erst mal umgewöhnen. Warum sollte ich denn? Also, das ist ein
ganz besonderes Thema. Also, da würde mich jetzt mal interessieren, was sind denn die
Vorteile? Ich meine, warum sollte ich eine komplett neue Programmiersprache lernen, die
sich auch komplett anders anfühlt und mit anderem, äh, eine andere Funktionsweise hat
als Programmiersprache, die ich kenne, plus ein neues Framework lernen? Was ist der Vorteil
davon? Also, was sind so die, wie sagt man so schön, die Selling Points? Ist das besonders
schnell, ist das besonders fehlerunanfällig, oder, ähm, ist das besonders gut multithreaded,
oder was sind die, was sind die Vorteile? Besonders schnell? Na ja, also, ganz ehrlich,
.NET Core, also ASP.NET Core ist eines der schnellsten Web-Frameworks der Welt. Ich
glaube nicht, dass das irgendwie bedeutend schneller ist. Das kann man besonders einfach
klustern, oder was? Aha, okay, das wäre natürlich, gerade in Zeiten von irgendwelchen hochverfügbaren
Web-Frameworks. Wenigstens sieht das Dashboard gut aus. Go. Okay, das erinnert mich ein bisschen
an, ähm, Sinatra Ruby, also an das Sinatra Web-Framework. Das war auch richtig, richtig
cool damals, das für minimale Web-Anwendungen. Guck mal, diese Webseite, guck mal, das ist
ein richtiger debated Hintergrund. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es von ihm so, so, ne. Usability
mindblown für mich, dass das hier eine vollständige Web-Anwendung ist. GORM. GORM hört sich an
wie irgendein Ork aus so einem Fantasy, aus irgendeinem Fantasy-Universum. GORM. SMOKE.
Okay. Und das sch collecte ich auch gerade. GORM. Und ich sch
bin wholesale eben cool vom地方 gelandet im Internet sow
Also, du musst wirklich wissen, was du tust.
Und das bringt uns in unsere nächste Sprache, Rust, und das Web-Framework Rocket.
Wie ich weiß, ist die Rust-Eco...
Rocket...
Das ist ja der... Wie soll ich sagen? Der...
Wie wäre so... Low Effort-Naming für den Framework.
Das System hat kein vollblonderes MVC-Framework wie Rails.
Und ehrlich gesagt fand ich es sehr schwierig, eine Basis-Applikation zu bauen.
My approach was to use Rocket for HTTP and routing,
then combine it with Diesel, which is a Rust-based ORM.
What?
And then finally a templating language to use the data in HTML...
Okay, das ist 5-Hat. Das ist typischer Rust-5-Hat-Kram.
Rust ist wirklich nur für 140 IQ-Plus-Leute gedacht.
I think this is a reasonable approach...
Guckt euch das mal an, schau, wie das ausschaut!
Also, versteht mich nicht falsch.
Rust ist eine super-nice Technologie.
Und gerade die Kombination aus, du kannst dich darauf verlassen,
dass du keine ungewollten Effekte in deinem Programm drin hast,
wenn es denn dann mal irgendwann kompiliert.
Und plus Performance, also dass du es quasi schaffst,
halbwegs memory-safe zu sein ohne viele Runtime-Checks und sowas.
Ist wirklich big brain in Rust.
Aber ich muss echt sagen...
Rust ist wirklich high IQ.
Und die Rust-Syntax ist auch wirklich sehr gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Also wer sich fragt, was das heißt...
Ich hab ja noch ein bisschen Ahnung im Hintergrund von Rust.
Also das hier ist der Return-Wert von der Funktion.
Wenn ein und davor ist, dann ist es eine Referenz.
Dieser Back-Tick hier oben, oder dieser normale Quote,
ist glaube ich irgendwas für die Lifetime des Objekts.
Warum es Static in dem Fall ist, habe ich keine Ahnung.
Alter, das ist...
Also Rust ist wirklich 6-Head.
Ach ja, und das ist Discard, das ist Return-Wert, nichts und so.
Was mich auch fertig macht, ist diese Syntax hier.
Dass du zuerst sagst, variable Name, und dann den Typ.
Das macht mich ultra fertig, ich mache es immer falsch rum.
Ich mache es immer falsch rum.
Swift!
Ich wusste, dass sowas kommt!
Richtig!
Richtig, Ruby on Rails ist das beste.
Da werden wir alle mal zum Rockstar-Programmer irgendwann.
Was machen wir denn jetzt hier?
Was der Swift Compiler ist aber auch nicht high IQ, der meckert wenn du zu viele Conditions
in einem IF hast.
Moment, wie viele Branches in deinem IF brauchst du, dass der Swift Compiler nicht mehr mit
klar kommt?
Wir haben schon mal Go gemacht im Stream, ich glaube für WebRTC haben wir mal Go gemacht
im Stream, irgendwann mal, mit Go, du kannst mit Go mehr oder weniger alles machen was
du auch mit den meisten anderen Programmiersprachen machen kannst, also der große Pluspunkt von
Go, oder einer, einer der großen Pluspunkte von Go ist, dass du Binaries rausbekommst,
die für sich Standalone lauffähig sind, ohne jegliche Abhängigkeiten.
Also wenn du ein Go Programm kompilierst, dann ist das lauffähig für, glaube ich rückwirkend
auf allen Linux Versionen seit Colonel 2.6.35 oder sowas, also die Colonel die die letzten
15 Jahre rausgekommen sind, läuft Go alles drauf, egal wie, statisches Binary, gib ihm
und es läuft, ansonsten hat Go noch ein paar andere Vorteile die jetzt vielleicht weniger
in der Sprache als eher im Ökosystem zu suchen sind, also zum Beispiel, dass im Cloud Umfeld
sehr viele Sachen in Go programmiert sind, dass du dementsprechend dort viele Tools in
Go findest, dass du viele Libraries in dieser Richtung in Go findest, dass Go auch viele
Tutorials hat und mal gut reinkommt, ich persönlich bin nicht der größte Fan von der Go Syntax,
mittlerweile gibt es Generics, ich finde Go ist an manchen Stellen zu umfangreich und
an manchen Stellen zu minimalistisch, dass du Variablen auf 3-4 verschiedene Varianten
deklarieren kannst finde ich merkwürdig und auf der anderen Seite wo es mir ein bisschen
zu minimalistisch ist, ist dass die zum Beispiel sagen, ja mach doch einfach 3 nested for loops
anstatt den Array mit einem Select hinten dran oder so, ja genau, die Sache ist halt
genau so gehts mir auch, die Sache ist halt die, dass du ohne Generics bisher noch nicht
mal gescheit Utility Functions überhaupt bauen konntest, da das jetzt vielleicht besser
ist.
Bestes Multithreading System, ja kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten, ja dass du Channels
mit dabei hast ist natürlich nice und dass du quasi mit Go, wo ja der Name der Sprache
herkommst quasi erst irgendwas starten kannst, wobei ich sagen muss, du musst dich dort
ja auch in Go um Multithreading Sachen kümmern, also du musst ja nach wie vor trotzdem Sachen
synchronisieren, Sachen locken und sowas in der Richtung, dass es im Prinzip auf normales
Multithreading rausläuft, immer nur weil du Go davor schreibst, anstatt Task Run oder
so machts das jetzt ja auch nicht viel anders, deswegen bin ich der Meinung für normales
Multithreading und ich weiß, dass Async Await erstmal pauschal kein Multithreading ist,
aber unter der Haube ist es das zum größten Teil trotzdem, normale Async Await Unterstützung
so wie sie es jetzt mittlerweile auch in Javascript haben und in C Sharp schon länger, finde ich
eigentlich da den sinnvollsten Ansatz, du kannst zu 95% so programmieren wie du es sequenziell
machen würdest, aber es blockt nicht und das ist eigentlich das was du brauchst in der
Regel und wenn du wirklich richtig Hardcore Multithreading Background Processing mit irgendwelchem
Zeug machen musst oder irgendwelche Suchindex aufbauen willst, was auch immer, dann kann
ich auch selbst von Hand Multithreading machen, ja, also es hat schon seine Vorteile aber
ja, es hat auch ein paar komische Sachen, das stimmt, glücklicherweise sind die meisten
Sachen mittlerweile nicht alle Standard Library technisch aber soweit ready, dass du direkt
Async Await machen kannst und nicht mal den Kram selbst in irgendwelche Promises rappen
musst, leider File Reader nicht, haben wir gestern gesehen, ne, ne, ne, ne, das ist genau
nicht der Sinn von Async Await, der wartet nicht auf das Result, der gibt zurück in
den aufrufenden Thread quasi, der sagt quasi ok ich brauch keine CPU Zeit mehr und springt
erst wieder da rein, wenn das Ergebnis dann da ist, das ist ja gerade der Sinn davon,
also wenn du zum Beispiel jetzt irgendeine GUI Anwendung hast mit dem Knopf und du drückst
diesen Knopf und im Hintergrund lädt der 5GB Daten aus dem Internet drunter, wenn du das
synchron machen würdest, dann wäre das gesamte UI geblockt, machst du das mit Async Await,
dann geht der Download an und an der Stelle wo Await steht, springt er zurück in den
UI Thread und lässt den UI Thread weiter seinen UI Scheiß machen und sobald das Ergebnis
da ist, dann springt er wieder an die Stelle rein, das heißt eigentlich ist Await irgendwie
bisschen missverständlich, es müsste eigentlich sowas wie Return Wait oder so heißen, also
der merkt sich das an welcher Stelle er die Ausführung unterbrochen hat und wenn das Ergebnis
da ist, springt er wieder rein, das sieht man auch Sharp Lab, das sieht man auch schön
wenn man irgendwie mal hier ein Beispiel machen, keine Ahnung.NET Framework irgendwie sowas
und nicht Assembler, ja das ist ok, keine Ahnung, ich weiß gar nicht ob man das überhaupt
so sieht, Task, hat das Auto Complete, ah ne, das ist natürlich doof, Using, ne System,
Task Threading, wo ist Task drinnen, Task, so, Task Delay, Await, Async, so, kommt mal
und hier siehst du, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht im Detail an, also nur mal so, was aus
einer Zeile Await, also Task Delay ist im Prinzip, der macht, der startet, sagen wir
mal ganz einfach, der startet im Hintergrund ein Thread mit einem Sleep drinnen von 1000
Millisekunden und dann wartet er hier auf das Ergebnis, was der aber in Wirklichkeit macht
ist, der baut sich eine State Machine zusammen und springt an der Stelle, wo das hier dann
anfängt zu plocken, raus und pausiert das ganze und springt dann erst wieder hier hin
zurück, wenn das Ergebnis da ist, das ist ziemlich, ziemlicher Five Head Shit, der da
im Hintergrund läuft, so, egal, weiter gehts, ne wobei, was sagt man, was sagt man, was
heißt weiter gehts, wir haben fürs Video fertig, Leute, es ist 12.19 Uhr, ich bin jetzt 3 Stunden
18 on, ich will nachher noch ein bisschen Programmier Stream machen, wir bauen hier, wir bauen
hier das Tool von gestern weiter, hier, der Label Champ, ich mein, guck mal, der Label
Champ, da sind wir gestern relativ weit gekommen, der Label Champ hat Icons, der hat einen QR
Card, den man einfügen kann und bewegen kann und sowas, da bauen wir nachher dran weiter,
ist der Stream gestern abgebrochen, ne, der Stream ist einfach dann fertig gewesen nach
dreieinhalb Stunden, irgendwann ist auch mal gut, ich kann mich auch nicht ewig konzentrieren,
moin Michael, 50 Trillionen, ich geh jetzt Mittag essen, Pepo-Fat-Time und nachdem ich
abgenommen hab, kann ich jetzt besonders viel fressen, weil ich bin immer noch im Minus,
okay, ich geb zu, das ist nicht der Weg, wie man weiter abnimmt, erstmal 8 Kilo, ne,
nicht 8, 7, 8, 1, 7, ungefähr 7 Kilo sind es tatsächlich, erstmal 7 Kilo abgenommen,
jetzt so viel fressen und sagen, ich bin immer noch im Minus, ich kann jetzt viel fressen,
das ist, wo ich das nicht gedacht hab, alles klar Leute, wir sehen uns, bis denn, see you.